[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
welcome welcome kids to fat man beyond
I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark Bernard hey
hey thank you for being here we're
coming to you live tonight from smog
Castle Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands New
Jersey uh put your hands together so the
folks at home know you're real
uh I was just we were having a
conversation right before the show
started and I wanted to finish the
conversation but I also felt like the
rest of the people at home can hear
because it wasn't very inside baseball
but it was at the same time I just got a
text from my child my 24 year old kid
and she was like I hear you're drinking
a lot of Celsius
and Celsius is going to sound like a
commercial but believe me after we're
done talking it's not a [__]
commercial
sells these are these drinks man that
you find are like 7-Eleven and stuff and
my kids sold it to me as a vegan drink
she's like it's vegan and she's like and
it's it's it like picks you up and stuff
she was drinking a bunch of orange ones
so I tried one and I was like you know
what it's not bad and then I found that
a grape and I love grape it reminds me
of like grape Welch's grape soda which I
grew up drinking so I've been you know
pretty addicted to this and what does it
say it says live fit so that's like
healthy right like because they say so
you know what I'm saying like at the top
it says no sugar no preservatives live
fit that's their whole thing and zero
calories and [__] and my kid was saying
like it's vegan so I'm like well this is
this is yeah this is nothing wrong with
this so I've been drinking a bunch of
them kid was here two weekends ago at
the theater when we did a Superman live
script reading and she saw me just pound
in Celsius and she's like how many of
those a day do you drink
and I was like 10 why
and she was like did you ever think it
got more caffeine than coffee I was like
well I don't drink coffee you know and
she's like but you're a [__] heart
attack victim she's like I really don't
think you should be having that much I
was like well how many am I supposed to
drink she's like like maybe three max a
day she's going honestly but like one I
was like [__] one
no like I
I'm really used to pounding these and
[__] so she made me like promise I'd go
down to one but her her boyfriend's here
now Austin
um is here in town and the [__] piece
of [__] ratted me out
and said he's drinking all the Celsius
and [__] I mean you know what you could
drink tell me grape soda
I know but this got all the sugar in it
this got like zero calories so I can
pound like 10 of these but apparently it
jeopardizes my Cardiology in some way
but it's like an energy drink it's like
you know Jason Muse was like oh yeah
this shit's like a Red Bull yeah so just
drink soda man
yeah but this says live fit
it's all about health and [__]
um kids how many people have traveled
from outside of New Jersey to be here
today
that's [__] right uh here it's
normally we do this on the other side of
the country at the scum and villani
cantina tonight we're doing it here at
smog Castle Cinemas and whatnot but uh
we still have the power of the scum and
villainy canteen on our side because
with us as always is bamf man give it up
for Banff man JC
fam
hi JC hello
you watch Ahsoka
uh I did I did watch hisoka all right so
you'll be able to talk about it later I
can chime in did you guys see it
uh I did
I did not I have feelings
okay we'll we'll share it'll be like
that sounds like very positive yeah I
have thoughts and feelings all right so
we'll talk about that in a bit
um how you been doing I've been good man
I've been good I uh this is this is the
second leg of my East Coast tour my
first leg was uh was to Ticonderoga New
York nice right like Ticonderoga exactly
uh there are two things of note in in
Ticonderoga New York there's an old
revolutionary era Fort Ticonderoga which
is why I went there because I was doing
some research for a thing and they have
a uh it's the original Set uh replica of
the original set for Star Trek the
Classic Series in Ticonderoga New York
like I got to see that yeah like some
dude was like I'm gonna rebuild all
these sets so we got a hold of the
original schematics and designs and just
[__] built the Enterprise
in what looks to be a strip mall in
Ticonderoga New York
do they sell tickets to it yeah I was
like 25 bucks ahead to like walk around
were you by yourself
surprisingly not there were others there
yeah like I showed up at like 3 30 and
like yeah next tour is at 3 45 I'm like
all right dope I'm just gonna walk
around and buy some [__] oh can I use
the bathroom yeah go ahead and wow down
the [__] Enterprise back in through
and hey there's bones's office it's in
the bathroom and I walked back out and
there's like 20 people in the [__]
Lobby to take this tour with me in
Ticonderoga New York
do you know where Ticonderoga New York
is nobody wow
why
ah see so you went to see the set yeah
it is surprising you were just shocked
there were that many people in
Ticonderoga at the same time who were
like I have an idea I mean I'll spend my
day and it's like there's 5 000 people
in Sacramento New York and like a tenth
of us were seeing this tour right at the
same time math overwhelmed you on this
one what is happening here and it is
pretty [__] dope though because it's
not screen used it's just somebody who
built a replica they have some screen
use props that they have acquired over
the years but it is just a we built it
to the specifications of school in and
of itself and they lit it well and it's
it's pretty [__] dope I'll just say
it like go to Ticonderoga New York buy
some pencils go on a tour
and uh and maybe see a fort and then you
could leave
and some travel [__] advice
in the same place in Ticonderoga they're
building Enterprise D I mean I guess
no I won't [__] with a d the D that's my
Enterprise
I won't [__] with the D
yeah I do
sounded so hardcore and then I was like
they're talking about Star Trek
I will [__] with a bloody a the bloody B
the bloody [__] C and the D
um it's how weird to stumble into that
and be like there's something to do here
I didn't think I was I was like oh I'm
done touring the fort uh and it's three
o'clock in the afternoon
and I drove past it literally by
accident it's like [__] it door
it was kind of dope so if you're up in
that area kids and what were you at a
comic book store or a show or what uh I
went to go tour for Ticonderoga just for
that just for that I was like I'm gonna
be in Jersey anyway how far is [__]
Fort to conorioga from New Jersey
like five hours
holy [__] I read I thought you were in a
place and you were like oh this place
happens to be here but you went to that
place I read-eyed from L.A to Newark
then to Albany then picked up a rental
car and drove two hours north of
Ticonderoga
straight to the [__] Fort walked
around the fort took a bunch of pictures
and video I'm writing a thing that I
might set in fortnite I'm gonna be there
it's just five hours North and treated
myself to a fort tour
treat yourself
most glamorous Fort Tour Ever what an
interesting life you lead it's the first
time I've ever done that I've ever done
like a research trip right like I'm a I
could say and you were researching for
Ticonderoga not Star Trek no I know
enough about Star Trek right but it just
happened to be there two birds one stone
yeah I didn't even expect to have to use
that other Stone
good to know man yeah uh and then you
came here and then I came here this
morning I drove down I left at eight
o'clock drove straight to New Jersey got
myself a [__] giant bagel with Taylor
ham and cheese on it
outside of Jersey otherwise nobody knows
what it is
um and got some some pizza because you
can't get that [__] in La yeah that's
true um in L.A there's only one pizza
that's easy to [__] with that's I mean
all pizza is edible pizza's like [__]
it's in a bad Pizza it's [__]
all pizza is amazing but they do pizza
at um Mulberry Street which is very much
like New York Pizza
there's a there's a it started in the
pandemic the pandemic seemed to be a
Haven for [__] in their house
trying to replicate [__] they couldn't
get outside anymore right and so there
was a dude who lived in East L.A it was
like I miss New Jersey boardwalk Pizza
specifically and so he like [__] did
all the work and he went into the lab
and he created what he called secret
pizza and if he went on his Instagram at
certain times of the day he would lower
a [__] box out of his apartment that
was filled with what he considered to be
authentic New Jersey pizza
and I know this [__] pandemic is
weird yeah and uh and since then like it
got so popular he had to like take over
pizzerias and do it and now he's got a
real brick and mortar place called
secret pizza and it's [__] dope
granted it's LA and so all it has to be
is like the shittiest Pizza you could
buy in New Jersey and it's the amazing
as Pizza you can get in LA but and it's
expensive and it's like an hour away
from my house but I bought it like five
times and I've spent like forty dollars
on a pizza
but it's [__] great I'd like to do
the chappie the guy who was a a working
actor in La during the pandemic missed
Philly style soft pretzels
and like just [__] made them in his
apartment over and over and over again
started giving away his friends then
selling it out of his house and now he's
got [__] brick and mortar and he's
been dropping him off at picket line
locations like who wants a [__]
pretzel but I want to [__] yeah man
speaking of which Hal has been uh the
struggle fighting the power the struggle
continues you've been out there I I've
been out there I ran into Harley uh this
week out there on Wednesday I was at uh
I was at Disney my kid was picketing you
she's like [__] yeah [__] you yeah
I'm spending too much time with him
um but no she uh she was out there she
was there for sag you were there for for
the WGN wga it was the day of solidarity
amongst all the unions so it was sagging
wga and the teamsters who were not
[__] around at all they will continue
to step on dicks
um and uh and ayatsi which is the sort
of the the cruise and the below the line
guys and and it was kind of [__]
amazing it's always amazing being on the
line but when there's a thousand people
2 000 people on a street all just kind
of growing in the same direction row of
humanity yeah and to hear [__] Martin
Sheen exhort us to action like President
Bartlett was like [__] step on the
man get what you need partly for America
I'm like yeah Martin Shane
I'll do whatever you tell me to do
um I mean that is kind of the charm of
that like Union very much like oh my god
the guy who's talking is a guy I've seen
in movies I know is that Ron Perlman is
it Hellboy at this [__] rally like
yeah hellboy's here what is going on in
the strike any progress no
no
uh no there's there had been some
conversations between the studios and
The Writers Guild right um that broke
down catastrophically because they
continue to treat us like we're children
and we continue to tell them that we're
not that we're grown and we wear big boy
shoes and adult pants and everything and
so we gotta get what we gotta get and so
now there's hopefully they're gonna sit
down again next week and hopefully
they'll sit down again the week after
that until we get a deal that we can
live with and I'll just [__] go back
to work
does it feel like two steps forward or
one step forward two steps back or no
steps in any direction
um the the big step was when the actors
joined us which meant that like I didn't
have to be the most attractive person on
the picket line anymore right so guys
this has been really heavy this load
it's it's tough on my shoulders but send
more beautiful people
it's just it's me
um and uh so now the pic the the actors
are here and so it's like a [__]
musical Fantasia like they were
literally doing West Side Story at
Universal the other day like Rachel blue
sharks and Jets for real and they want
to know a girl named Maria and they're
like great I don't have to show up that
day because I don't know the words to
any of those songs
have you seen and other than Martin
Sheen have you seen other famous people
there
in if you looked at the other face
they're kind of incognito because like
they're all like overgrown like beards
like there's things actors do when
they're not on camera means they grow
like bushy ass beards or whatever right
but then you see them like they're all
got their guns out their arms are all
bare and it's like oh you must be an
actor yeah you work out like on the
regular because you're not because your
doctor told you you should walk more
but I did say I saw Bob I wouldn't Kirk
the other day I saw Nathan feeling the
other day I saw Kerry Washington the
other day
um I mean they're out there they don't
even have to promote anything do you
still get is there any party that's like
that [__] person's famous
um if you get Star Struck at all even on
any level
a Teensy bit like I saw Viola Davis the
other day and I was like oh [__] you
[__] are in for it now [__] the
woman really good actress she's got
Oscars and [__] you guys never mind
Nathan Philly and that's [__] Viola
Davis that's the queen of all she
surveys uh not that often but
occasionally I'm like [__] yeah
and I get a picture no that's weird
just just walk behind her into the left
I remember when I was a kid
1995 I was in uh Universal and we were
in the commissaries me and Scott Mosher
Jim Jack's mirror in the process of
making Mall Rats either pre-production
or post
and we went to eat lunch in the
commissary which is just like the
restaurant on campus
and Sean Connery who was sitting there
right next to our table and the whole
[__] meal like me and Moser knew
better we knew it's like hey man like
we're no we're not Rubes we're trying
not to be rubed so it's like ice front
and [__] like that but it was [__]
Sean Connery
doing every simple thing and so like we
would [__] look over try to talk and
be casual and then [__] look over and
I'd be like Sean Connery's eating soup
is unbelievable and we would try to do
this [__] and just watch him
eat his soup and you would see him like
look over and see us [__] looking but
everything that [__] did was
like he does it too
with an H Salt doesn't have an H
Stars they're just like us
it was [__] dope man
um let's uh get to our sponsor real
quick before we dive into our show
proper kids we have a sponsor to thank
the Lord somebody believes in us enough
to advertise at the beginning of fat man
beyond and that sponsor tonight is the
good Folks at Emmy eats go to immi eats
i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s.com slash fat man right
now
you get five bucks off your first uh
order man while we sit here and talk
about Emmy eats Emmy makes Ramen that's
vegan and really really good
um they don't make it necessarily with
uh animal ingredients hence the vegan
part of it
um they do low carb high protein time
crunch
life-changing [__] food man now I've
eaten it on more than one occasion
because I just used to love ramen and
then I had to stop because I went vegan
but now they've found a way to do it
where it's like oh this tastes like
chicken but it's not chicken it's
chicken or whatever the [__] so many
apostrophes in your food so many
um but I absolutely dig it have you
[__] with this yet I did and I at
first I treated it the way I usually
treat vegan food which is like no
and then it's like I'll
and I was like oh [__] this [__] it
slaps it does right surprisingly so not
be I mean it's possible for vegan food
to taste good uh hence Celsius
but that's good for you but every time I
I encounter and it's good it's it's like
milk with caffeine and sugar
concentrate on Emmy yes uh I did not
expect it to taste as good as it did uh
to the point where I ate it twice which
is not a thing that I often do with
vegan look at that man that's proof that
he was into it Emmy is the tastiest way
to put carbs uh to cut carbs from your
diet so you feel better every day this
tasty uh high protein
vegan ramen allows you to stay full
longer keeps you energized and keeps you
on track for your health goals man
well acted that was [__] fantastic I
was trying to be like the energetic
person like having to sign Baby Got Back
you were
you're like that dude in The Mighty
Mighty Boss Tones it just dances behind
him keeps the energy in the flavor flame
yes he was a total flavor flavor that
moment yeah me
stay lean each packet of Emmy has only
five grams of net carbs keeping me lean
and active man you get more protein in
your diet with up to 22 grams of protein
three times more than the traditional
Brands m is perfect for a pre or post
workout meal so essentially anytime
but while you're working out they don't
recommend eating it
uh prevent you from eating junk food yes
helps you stay in shape
to throw up the guns very nice you get
to eat ramen again man they've got 300
calories and 85 percent less net carbs
than normal instant Ramen so you don't
have to feel guilty about eating
something you love it improves your gut
health with 18 grams of fiber which is
amazing for gut health and digestion
and go to meeats.com Fatman or using the
code Fatman at checkout to get five
dollars off your order that's
emmyeats.com Fatman to get five bucks
off give it up for the good Folks at me
eats
any sponsor in our show
okay we did it thanks for coming
everybody yes there it is
um all right what do we got to talk
about well we got some news and we have
some reviews what would you like to
start with let's start with reviews
you've seen everything right uh
almost
but I've seen enough we're gonna dive
into some [__] if uh it's spoilerific
and you don't want to hear it
leave leave yeah
or just do this [__] la la quietly to
yourself uh but we're gonna spoil some
flicks and TV shows that have been out
what do you want to start with uh let's
start let's go old to new okay uh did
you see the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Mutant Mayhem I did not
I didn't but I hear it's wonderful how
wait don't you own a movie theater I do
but would you live upstairs I do I
should have seen it for free but I have
not seen it yet and everyone who I know
has seen it loves it
um it's really you hated it
okay it is fantastic it's good I very
much dug it this is the one that Seth
Rogen did this is the Seth Rogen Jamie
Jam
um that it owes quite a bit to into the
spider-verse okay in that into the
spider-verse was this kind of like
Paradigm shifting artistic [__]
boundary breaking movie that let
animation look different than it ever
looked before and this is like the the
next phase in like it just it looks like
art I mean it looks like somebody drew
this [__] movie to the point where
you know it it it's kind of sketchy at
times it's a little loose at times the
ability to make that as a computer
animated movie is kind of phenomenal
um the performances are great like they
got [__] teenagers to play Teenagers
and not like 30 year old men trying to
pretend to be like gosh RAF
they're actually [__] kids and they
did this thing where I mean you've made
animated things most of the time it is
an actor in a booth by themselves or
quoting their lines and then you'll kind
of put the scene together in editorial
they put those four kids in a [__]
room together and let them do it and
just let them do it and so all of this
buy play all of this conversation all
these just little moments that you get
when you put kids in a room together to
be kids
it's so [__] refreshing it doesn't
sound as sterile as it can sound it
sounds like a bunch of teenagers who
like each other hanging out together and
that in and of itself makes it this this
kind of wonderfully Rich experience
um and they monkey with the origin story
a little bit but it makes perfect sense
for the movie okay
um they explain where the use comes from
they all the bad guys are kind of out of
the same moves that made the good guys
spoilers there's ooze I guess
um secrets of that ooze you know there
may or may not even be in a whose song
yeah
that makes sense yeah I heard they did
t-u-r-t-l-e power yeah they do did they
really yeah it's pretty deep Cuts right
there very much so
um but it's super [__] fun it's like
89 minutes long so I think you would
love it you're nice and short you've got
you've got a length Kink
um short of the bed I wouldn't call it a
kink I
just prefer things to be on the
shoulders how long is this movie is it
86 minutes I'm in
I don't have that much time for a lot of
Hogan lengthy thing I mean I hate to
admit I have not had a chance
to see Oppenheimer yet
is it I it came and went we it finally I
think it left this theater uh this week
so I missed my chance to see it here
um but I'll see it don't worry I just
haven't had a chance on your phone as
Christopher Nolan intended like
boy he did a good job oh this IMAX is
great
I did see Barbie twice though did you
yeah
did I ran it again at one point for
Malcolm my friend Malcolm and I was like
oh I'll [__] watch it again and it
[__] held up what a wonderful movie
that is they're re-releasing it in IMAX
I think in a couple of weeks what they
hadn't done that no and but now it's got
like new post-credit scenes
they've sweetened the deal in case it
hadn't already made more money than any
other Warner Brothers domestic release
ever it needs to make a little bit more
that's smart marketing I would [__]
re-watch that movie if they were like
now with more ship that's like how they
sell Barbie not with the hat
um all right so turtle's worth saying
absolutely if you can find it I'm sure
it'll be on streaming in like a week
um I think it's still here I think we
held on to it
I'm not sure that's smart Castle but it
was here all right what else you got uh
Blue Beetle that's here that's still
here that's definitely here did anybody
else see Blue Beetle
how are your thoughts
um I uh I I dug it it's it's an origin
story and so it has a lot of origin
story stuff in it right and I'll be
candid I'm a little tired of origin
story stuff because it always feels a
bit like every other origin story right
um like it's it's very Greatest American
Hero it's like I found this thing I
don't know how to use it there's a bad
guy who I've never met but has powers
kind of like mine
I kind of don't and there's a big
Showdown with a bad guy who looks kind
of like me also in armor we're gonna
fight in the sky like you may or may not
have seen a movie like that before
um I mean fakingly familiar a little bit
achingly familiar but like the lead
actor Zolo whose last name I'm not even
using Cobra Kai he's in Cobra Kai he's
Charming great yeah like he's just super
fun like I I always ride for movies that
are very specific about who they're
about and where they're from
and so to see like your first real
Latino latinx Latina superhero and his
family and his world is so [__] great
very men's Marvel right very Miss Marvel
very you know the the thing that I
always want though is that
my favorite example of that is Miles
Morales yeah my favorite example of most
things is Miles Morales at this point
but into the spider-verse it is very
very clear that he is an afro-latino kid
right who lives in New York and but it's
not about him being an afro-latino kid
who lives in New York but you'll never
mistake it for anything else right you
know the easy sort of just the language
drops out when like they're Spanish and
there's no subtitles like either you
know it or you don't right like the
music he listens to was very [__]
specific
like so it's about him being that
without the movie being about that right
whereas this movie gets a little heavy
at times about like okay he's Latin
American and we're going to talk about
immigration and we're going to talk
about the border and we're going to talk
about and talk about I'm like hey I get
it
this may or may not be the only time you
get to do this so just [__] load it
with all of this [__] but I I love it
when it's more character based and not
plot-based right
um and they spent a lot of [__] money
on this movie there's about they were
doing it as a um max well back then as a
HBO Max movie no as an HBO Go movie I
think it even started is that right
that's how long it's been in development
and their budget was like a hundred
million or just a hair under yeah it was
like 90 million and then an inflated to
150 and then like dropped back down to
90. but either way
all of that is kind of too expensive for
this kind of movie right and I'm always
just like you know what they made John
Wick for 40 million dollars right they
may Attack the Block for 15 million
dollars they made District 9 for 30
million dollars like if you've got a
movie that you're not sure there's an
audience for but you're taking a gamble
then [__] make it cheap yes if you
can so that way there's just more upside
and so this movie needs to make 500
million dollars to to to be profitable
for Warner Brothers it never will right
and so it kind of sets itself up for
failure and it's hard to spectacleize
any anymore you know like we've seen
everything we've seen dragons we've seen
armor we've seen Thanos like there's
nothing you can do on a screen that will
make me go oh [__] did you see what they
did except for like Avatar 2 and that's
James Cameron and that's billions of
dollars poured into the screen and even
then we're like oh well yeah look
it's a space whale who can talk though
it's a space whale
you know and so spectacle is not enough
anymore right like we we need character
we need plot we need surprises we need
Innovation and that's the stuff that's
kind of free right like that's all on
the page and so don't even try to dazzle
me with a big armor fight that's CG at
the end like it's not gonna be better
than end game and you can't compete with
it so just Zig what everybody else is
zagging like don't spend this money
deliver it and I mean we've talked about
it before like it astonishes me that
there's a Batman movie that costs 250
million dollars to make yeah it's a
[__] dude in a suit who drives a car
that's practically every movie and
punches people I'm like how is this
costing me 200 million dollars you're
shooting in Chicago right like you're
not building a city in the desert like
huh yeah I agree and this one had to be
more because it's got special effects
the suit does everything he's got like
an Iron Man suit of sorts right and I
like still it's like why would you risk
that much on this isn't even the Blue
Beetle that is like insanely well known
over decades Ted cord this is kind of
the newer Blue Beetle who's been around
for a while and has been in the Animated
Series but it was always just kind of a
risky character to jump out there with
when they were like in the midst of the
streaming Wars they're like we're doing
everything [__] it we'll do Blue Beetle
that makes sense for them to be like
well let's bring it to theatrical that
was always very surprising this over
Batgirl
is what got the nod it was between this
and Batgirl and this moved forward and
that girl got written off yeah I mean
and there's some there's some legit
humor there's some really great jokes
and the the character the family all
that stuff is really rich but it is like
and again the the Latino Market is
vastly untapped and so I get it like
let's go get this money if your
executive who uh can occasionally make
good decisions like yeah let's go get
that [__] money
but let's also hedge our bets let's
Money Ball this a little bit more right
and this is not a moneyballed movie
um will it have a sequel
um not at this rate I don't think but it
wouldn't surprise me if Blue Beetle
factors into whatever else one of the
next flicks like Superman Legacy yeah
like you know Big Jim Gunn will find a
place for that guy I decided he's like a
wrestler now like big Jim Gunn
lots of people been like hanging his
name on flash and Blue Beetle to keep
going like James guns flash James guns
Blue Beetle but I'm like he got there
before like all that [__] was going on
before he got there so that's not his it
don't really kick off until he takes off
with Superman right right and that's 20
25. Jesus that's so long away
um all right well but for now Blue
Beetle Blue Beetle I'm
just a thumbs up but it's like a good
time and it's like 95 minutes long they
stuck The Landing oh I love that [__] I
see
sounds amazing the Kink is real
um all right what else are we talking
about
um
well you know what I saw before I came
here today
um I went to the movies today
this movie theater no because you don't
have this movie at this movie what is it
Gran Turismo I saw today oh you went to
see that I did because I was a [__]
player back in the day
uh that's based on a video game it's
based on a video game and more to the
point based on a true story surrounding
the video game which is at some point in
I'm going to say it was like the early
2000s
um Nissan decided to hold a contest to
find the best Gran Turismo players in
the world and invite the 10 best of them
to a GT Academy they call it Gran
tourism Academy and the best who
performed in this Academy which took
place behind actual [__] cars right
got to join the Nissan uh racing team
and it's about this kid
um whose name is uh something
martinborough martinborough can't
remember his [__] first name uh
starts with a J
Jess
Jai no okay uh anyway uh but who joins
who who did this he was a great player
at home he [__] into this competition
wins it goes into [__] the GT Academy
number one in his class it's like a real
life Last Starfighter a hundred percent
The Last Starfighter where they're like
you [__] are so good at this game we
want you to do it for real yeah
join us and fight code
that's so [__] up that really happened
it really happened it'd be like the real
guy and again it's like you could drive
real well in a video game come do it in
real life yes come sit behind the wheel
of this hundred thousand dollar race car
that goes like 250 miles an hour and
maybe don't die hope you don't die
and that happened and that happened
did the Kid die
I'm right now I'm really intrigued uh he
did not because
listen dude it's a sports movie it's
[__] it's it's Rudy plus driving
so it's going to end triumphantly you're
then going to see like archival footage
of the actual real dude who did it like
he made it he made it and he was a stunt
driver in the actual movie my [__] isn't
so much that he Jan that's it
so much that he uh it's that he wins I
was hoping it was more like a Bad News
Bears were like he went all the way and
then he [__] lost well yes that's the
end of the second act where he [__]
loses and then it's like I'll go put
myself back together I'll go get behind
the wheel of this car I've got to I've
got a [__] win to prove to everybody
back in the ends that I'm not a [__]
[__] is he British yeah oh all right
so I was like I think you're having a
stroke
that was pretty good he's played by
Daniel caluya as Hobie from across the
spider verse I've always been this cool
good uh
a dope like I didn't expect much from
this movie right and it was surprisingly
effective because it's a sports movie
and we are preconditioned to understand
the rhythms and the beats and the
emotional Stakes of a sports movie and
as long as the guy you want wins or wins
the emotional story if not the plot
story like it's Rocky right like we
don't care if he wins or not that long
he wins as long as he has the popular
vote it's all good yep yes it is yes
yes it is
um but no it was it's it's it's two
hours long it's a little long for you oh
what the [__]
two hours about [__] fake racing and
then Real Racing yes which is all fake
racing
yes
it's a long time the cats like the
Oppenheimer a video game
but uh but it was technically a video
game movie technically a video game
movie so technically dovetails in to the
fat man beyond uh Mission State audience
yeah truly wow [__] hey man yeah all
right so that's another thing God you've
been busy I'm trying to pull my weight
man
trying to trying to lift the all Tides
um Tides what's the last thing the last
thing we'll talk about is uh a Little
Star Wars television show folks how many
people saw Ahsoka
okay and how many people before they
watched Ahsoka had seen all of Star Wars
Rebels
and like most of the Clone Wars
[Applause]
okay you all were far better prepared
for Ahsoka than I was
foreign
damn right uh yeah those cartoons go
deep some people run deep on those
animated series I mean and I I get it if
you if you hit second Clone Wars at the
right age at the right time uh it was
mother's milk because we didn't have a
[__] ton of Star Wars in the world right
that was carrying the banner flying the
flag for Star Wars and uh and and I get
it to a degree
uh I was not one of those people
um Clone Wars I watched some of the
first season of Clone Wars I'm like
there's a hundred percent too much jar
jar in this for me
and uh and I say that as a person who
knows Ahmed best who's a lovely lovely
man but too much jar jar for me
um and so I kind of just tapped out and
I tried to revisit it during the
pandemic and I got like a season and a
half in and we didn't get to the cool
[__] yet and kind of tapped out there
and then when I saw they were doing the
show I was like all right bet somebody
tell me the 10 Ahsoka episodes to watch
and I did I'm like oh
okay
she's cool like I dig the character I
understand it right
um and I never that's the one where she
faces off against Darth Vader no because
I was in Rebels he's in Rebels and I saw
the first two episodes of rebels and I
was like I'm not feeling it and never
went back that I I didn't [__] with the
whole show but I definitely [__] with
that story arc I found it through a
series of YouTube clips you know and
YouTube editors will take a show that's
like too long and make it real watchable
laughs so I saw the entire Ahsoka and
Anakin Darth Vader Arc which was
incredibly powerful especially
considering that I don't go very deep on
the character but knowing what that
character was and some of the limited
stuff I did see watching their
relationship hit this place where you
know it was very much like Darth Vader
and beg Adobe was quite thrilling they
did some amazing things with that
character that you like [__] this should
be Canon never mind some of the other
[__] they've done and now it sounds like
or feels like they're making all that
[__] Canon yeah you know and like listen
I am 100 on board for you if you love
Rebels I'm 100 on board for you if you
love Clone Wars the issue that I had
with this show is that for the first
time it felt as if I needed to have
watched both to understand and
appreciate and be invested in what
happened here is that right you were
like who the [__] is Ezra Bridger I was
like the aunt who's Sabine went but I
don't know who's this person I don't
know who
I don't know
these people all seem that this is
important but I don't know and and it
was the first time that that Star Wars
made you feel like a little old man it
all who are all these new people around
here I I don't know them that ain't Star
Wars well it for the first time for me
it felt like a like a Walled Garden yeah
in that previously on Star Wars if you
came to the first chapter of any Trilogy
right episode one episode four episode
seven
you didn't need to have previous
knowledge like it taught you how to
watch it it told you what was important
as you were doing it like I didn't know
what a clone war was I didn't know what
a Jedi was when I showed up for a New
Hope and it taught me that like who's
the big bad guy that one in the big
black hat like he's the bad guy what
does he do the first time you see him
bad guy [__] all right I know he's the
bad guy who are your Heroes these people
do they have a relationship not really
but the old guy does like it helps you
form these connections that help you
follow the plot even if you don't know
because I know there are kids who saw
the [__] prequel trilogy and had
never seen
a star war and so you could watch those
movies and still understand what it was
if you'd seen the the OG Trilogy all of
this had context and importance and you
could attach your own emotional
connection to it but the movie taught
you who to care about and taught you
their relationships and now
I watch the soak I'm like I don't know
what the relationship is between Ahsoka
and Sabine it seems like there probably
is one but I don't know what it is when
they meet each other there's no response
emotionally from anybody
and so like all right so she's got her
arms crossed because that's what Ahsoka
seems to do and the other one is like
rebellious for reasons I don't know and
oh did they used to like is this one are
they both Jedi I'm not sure they both
have lightsabers
sure maybe she's a Jedi and my friends
are like no not at all this was a whole
thing if you would watch these 12
episodes or whatever I'm like
but I shouldn't have to you know like
it's weird that this is being visited
upon us because we've spent so many
years talking other people going like
well you just don't know the back story
and now we've finally reached a place
where the people are like well you just
don't know the backstory
like how am I supposed to watch this and
explain it to my wife that was my
favorite part about watching Marvel
shows during the pandemic was because I
could re-watch him and then she'd be
like what the [__] going on I'd be
like pause let me tell you the whole
story it goes way back to Iron Man first
so now we've reached a place where
somebody's gonna have to pause and
explain to us like old men
um but like like I love stories that
have history within them right like I I
think back to Raiders the Lost Ark yes
when you first meet Marion yes like you
don't know the history between her and
Indiana Jones but in that first scene
like oh you get it that like he's being
kind of [__] chilly she's being very
angry with him there's some [__] that he
did in the past that she didn't love but
now she's gonna force him to kind of
apologize so that she can get what she
wants and he can get what he wants like
you can it's the second movie you've
broken down without using any words from
the movie that made me want to watch the
movie again like you just did the same
thing about stories you're like he's the
guy in Black and then these cats are
just mean but they met the old guy once
I was like that sounds like a good ass
movie
and then when you just describe Indiana
Jones I was like [__] that sounds good I
don't even have to get to like but I was
young and I was in love
young probably
uh you're talking about Marion yeah yeah
yeah that is a whole other [__] story
you guys yeah did you we talked about
this before right we did because he she
even says it in the movie she's like I
was in love I was a child you're like ah
and like there you can find it online
there's there's a transcript of what
they call the Raider story sessions
which was between Lawrence Kasdan Steven
spieler bringing George Lucas as they
were they ran a tape quarter while they
were breaking down the story of wild of
the of the movie
and uh and there was a conversation
about how young Marian was
and one person in that triumvirate
wanted her to be very young like 13 or
14 years old young who was it
I'm not gonna say
but you can do the research it's on the
internet and the other two people were
like that's too young George
[Laughter]
oh
[Applause]
perfection
really yeah yeah
so you know what American Graffiti has
that teenage girl in it too
I think we're [__] on to something
here oh wow and so but so when you watch
that movie like you get the emotional
diagram of their relationship right I
don't know
Ahsoka and Sabine I don't know who Ezra
Bridger was other than they made a
painting of him I don't know who Grant
Admiral thrawn is because we never see
him we know all we hear is oh he's
coming back yeah that's bad right maybe
okay uh we should go and find this
[__] Apple of Destiny and maybe
it'll help lead us to one and or both of
the people who are not in this scene
there's another like we got to find a
thing that leads to a star map thing yes
big fans of star Maps yeah they really
are lately man they're not the plot of
the whole last Star Wars movie uh yeah
like we found a [__] machine that
lets us find the old Empire and then we
gotta decode the thing that will maybe
lead us to the person who is important
to us they're doing that again
so far
and like listen I'm always here for
Rosario Dawson she's always [__]
great
but it seems as if the direction for her
is like cross your arms and like glare
and then maybe do some cool Jedi [__]
with lightsabers and then glare some
more
and like she can do anything yeah it's
just a little frustrating for her to not
get to do anything and I thought that
was the [__] point of Ahsoka right
like from what I understand she was the
person who left the Jedi Order because
she didn't agree with their [__] like
strictures and rules about emotional
investors so she's like I'm done with
this like you guys like this is the
reason why you get a Darth Vader this is
the problem with the Jedi and so I'm
[__] out deuces peace I'll see you
and that was right before Order 66 right
right so that's why she's alive still
and so where is that and that hasn't
happened in this yet or it has happened
it has happened it's in the past because
they're very much like they're Jedi
alive like there's a and so Anakin is
Darth Vader at this point
um yes yes she's stamp
Darth Vader's gone Ahsoka takes place
concurrent with Mandalorian so like so
this is in return post return this is
post return to the Jedi she's met grogu
she knows Luke this is in that time
period
but isn't this also like don't they
recreate [__] from Rebels specifically
in that first pilot episode or the first
two episodes so doesn't it like sink
into the rebels timeline it does sin
yeah I mean it does in that like lothal
is the planet that they're all hang out
at in Rebels but it's been five years
like lothal is like kind of destroyed
and beaten up and crappy in Rebels and
now it's like a Cosmopolitan City
so it's been since Rebels it's been like
five eight years essentially they're
saying it's Rebels season fives that
sound right to you yeah if Rebels season
five took place eight years after Rebels
season four ended
wait but you're saying this is Rebel
Ahsoka is yeah I think he's saying it's
uh the continuation of season five is
what Ahsoka feels like if it took place
eight years later though right like
Rebels ends at a new hope
and then there's three years of the
original trilogy and then this is five
years post Return of the Jedi did you
[__] hard with the cartoons
I watched all the cartoons
so like when you watched Ahsoka where
you're like I get it 100 or did you need
a catechism as well the things that
excited me most about Ahsoka were the
things that referenced the heir to the
Empire book from 1991 not the stuff they
called back to
Rebels
um
that's what got me excited and
granddaughter out of that too it's just
like I shouldn't have to [__] go to
the library and do the reading
that's why I watch TV and movies so I
don't have to do the [__] readings
says that person like yeah but if you
entered the MCU at Ant-Man 2 you'd
probably be like what the [__] is this
1978's [__] Ant-Man issues you know
what it was I'd watch Ant-Man one
um but yeah I mean you don't need to the
book stuff is like exciting for me
because I read that book when I was 10
years old the not essential to enjoy but
not essential yeah not essential
the but you do have to watch those shows
to care
what do you think of Ahsoka
um I loved that it felt very much like
those Timothy Zahn books that I loved in
the dark ages of Star Wars when we were
never going to get any more Star Wars
um I thought the Mind's Eye type of Star
Wars yeah and I thought that the in the
first episode I thought it was shot very
cinematically and pretty cool
um
I every time I see another dark Jedi
did we lose it yeah I just sounds like
you're struggling for something nice to
say every show I don't know why we need
another dark Jedi and a dark Jedi robe
with a Apprentice every show you know
like
I've watched a lot of Star Wars fan
films and they're all like what if there
was a Mandalorian who is also a Jedi and
then in Ahsoka they're like what if we
took Sabine Wren who was a Mandalorian
and we made her a Jedi and I was like
cool like that's been in every fan film
since Kevin Rubio did
uh I was gonna say clerks Kevin Rubio
didn't do clerks Kevin Rubio did uh
troops uh you know so I just I feel like
I've watching the highest budget fan
film I've ever seen in a way because
like you are I mean they put together by
Dave filoni right but the ideas seem
very like
read
hashed in a lot of ways
um so I wasn't super super excited about
it yeah man if somebody told you years
ago we're gonna give you a [__] Star
Wars show you'd have been like oh oh
please I wouldn't and I got that I've
got so many Star Wars show they're like
nah this one's not to my taste put this
one back
the the last Star Wars show we saw
though was Andor
which didn't have any lightsabers and
didn't have anything and was just
magnificent from start to finish
any previous knowledge to show up for
Andor just be [__] good and just you
know in the world and tell me a story
that's all I want I don't I don't want
the cliff notes to have to figure out
like who's that what do they have to do
with this who's the bad guy like just
[__] tell me and I'll figure it out
I feel like after two episodes it's only
two episodes but after two episodes I
think it's but I I have enjoyed it more
than I enjoyed book of Boba Fett
and I probably liked it more than
Mandalorian season three
but it doesn't touch Mando season one or
two or not even playing in the same
league as Andor was
and that's only been what two episodes
so far yeah it's about an hour and 15 in
how many episodes they do in total
seven or eight I think eight yeah so
they still got time to capture your
heart I mean it'll be cool again like
the plot of the show is the book that I
loved when I was a kid so like I'm ready
for it yeah heir to the Empire but it's
not
like Andor was just so good I think
you're following some I think you're
they're trying to follow the best Star
Wars since you know 1983 in my opinion
or 1980 and most people's opinion who
weren't children when Return of the Jedi
came out so
and or not really a kid's show though
right doesn't really capture a child's
imagination
politics
I want to be that boring guy I'll be the
other boring guy nobody whips out a
lightsaber or anything right no there
are no lightsabers the show of like hey
man when you think of Star Wars you
don't think a motherfucker's talking you
think it is [__]
there's a lot of [__] talking in
Ahsoka yeah there's like one like we're
still in the thing from the cave like
[__] uh Star-Lord and then there's
like conversations about [__]
and then maybe another fight at the end
of those 45 minutes and it's a lot of
like hmm reefing scene
she's not gonna want to talk to you hmm
well maybe she will
okay let's walk in this hangar
May the Harem be with you I I just feel
like having watched the cartoons and
maybe I'm partial because I did watch
you know hours and hours of the cartoons
like I want to say like the Hera
character was like
oh God I'm gonna get killed for
something
better
acted in the cartoon and in live action
and actually like kind of like looked
more realistic like the makeup
doesn't look great on the characters you
know
the Ahsoka makeup is good but like the
Hera makeup is kind of weird and like
strangely less realistic than the
cartoon was I don't know I'm probably
getting killed in the chat room
don't go read the comments bro welcome
to my world everybody in the chat room
was like here goes Mark he's gonna [__]
on Ahsoka where's JC to save the day and
I was like
what about the mention of the new Galaxy
there's a new Galaxy
a galaxy of Wonder a galaxy of dreams
and hope two galaxies there's a Galaxy
beyond the one
right it's like they're hanging yeah
he's hanging out where the spaceship was
at the end of Empire Strikes Back
looking back on the other Galaxy like
it's not not a new idea like outbound
flight project written by Timothy Zahn
and the entire New Jedi Order oh this is
just recycled no wonder you [__] knew
it so well Mark's I'm [__] lost
worth watching though or no worth
watching but mid
oh the worst thing you could say on the
internet
mid [__] I'd rather be called not worth
watching than mid
presumably most of my [__] is always not
worth watching but mid hurts man [__] I
mean I'll watch it for Rosario because
again I'm a huge [__] fan yeah but I
just I I want it I want it to engage me
I wanted to to help [__] hold me by
the hand and tell me what I'm supposed
to care about like [__] Mando season
one even though I was a little and
they've learned about it at the jump I
was like oh but it doesn't require me to
know anything right other than to do the
helmet I think he's a Mandalorian sure
let's go [__] bounty [__] let's go do
it and he's got the [__] kid with him
there's no grogu there's nothing for me
to emotionally invest myself in there's
just kind of adults having quiet
conversations about [__]
can I also add the thing that drove me
nuts about Kenobi which also they did
like right off the bat in this and sorry
spoilers but like
she gets stabbed by a lightsaber and
then has a little Blister in the morning
and it's like time to go fight again
like Obi-Wan Kenobi was murdered by a
lightsaber we saw lightsabers kill
people for
30 40 years and now like anybody who
gets stabbed by disappeared atomized
Obi-Wan Kenobi yeah now everybody who
gets stabbed by a lightsaber it's like
burning yourself on a hot pan like what
is going on
anyway it rant over once again man it's
like [__] what a rarefied generation
this is where like you'll [__] about
man you should die from a lightsaber of
strike we have so much Star Wars now
they're like we can't kill everyone who
touches a lightsaber
and like I I also had a little
lightsaber-y pet peeve like Jedi were
modeled after Samurai yeah abundantly
clearly yes a samurai duel
lasted like 18 seconds long because
every stroke was a killing stroke either
you didn't block it or you [__] died
these lightsaber fights go on for like
10 [__] minutes and all they're doing
is whamming lightsabers together like
none of these are killing blows they're
not even trying to be we're just gonna
fence for a while right what is this
garbage like [__] kill that person
like what what why are you all so bad at
this
yeah just [__] like oh bam bam bam
bam junk and go home
and also like I'm sure Jay-Z has an
answer for this
um why doesn't any Jedi use the force to
turn off the other dude's lightsaber
[Applause]
we've now we have so much Star Wars in
our lives we've now reached the
inevitable Clerk's point where the
audience starts breaking it down and
being like this don't make sense let's
make fun of this but you're absolutely
right if everyone's [__] got the
force just be like click yeah what click
click it's just a series of turning it
on and turning it off like flashlights
in the darkness there's no moves it's
just going on and off like click click
click click click click and then you
just keep moving the beam closer to each
other
it's considered what dishonorable
there's an answer for this already
that [__] rocks all right hold on
there's a real answer it's considered
dishonorable to turn off the other
person's
bad sportsmanship
Sith has an opinion on sportsmanship
they're like you can't turn that [__]
off that's you know as bad as we are
that's really bad
pardon me how evil are we oh not that
evil though we'll kill an entire [__]
planet we will kill Alderaan but I will
not turn your lightsaber off sir I will
kill a room full of children
but do not [__] switchy switchy My
lightsaber you snap my [__] off and
you're a monster just a monster
goddamn living rank or beast
that's hysterical and what's even better
is that you know that how do you know
that
that matters whether you're a wuss or
not in the Star Wars Universe because
I'd be like I don't give a [__] if
anyone sees me as a wuss I don't want to
get burned by a lightsaber
so that's it if it's too Sith Sith on
Sith action
it's dishonorable to turn off a Sith
because you're going like you're lower
than a [__] Rebel or whatever the
[__] like you're not even good enough to
be Sith and you know we're the Bad Guys
[__] hey
bamf
oh [__]
nerd fighting I'm just all right hold on
we got another explanation go ahead what
is it hold on JC what is it
when you're dealing with Force sensitive
folks
and they're fighting each other
he's reading a Legends of the Sith book
s
that you can't turn a lightsaber off
all right hold on one sec guys I gotta
translate this to everybody including
the [__] bunch of people at home so
what we're finding out from the audience
is when they fight they put up this kind
of force bubble of sorts that wouldn't
even allow an opponent to turn their
[__] off they're like that's level one
[__]
if the physical fight of lightsaber
against lightsaber but also
the mental fight as well
again Force against Force
[__] a all right I mean it all sounds
to me like now we're gonna have a third
yeah it all sounds to me like this all
started when Mickey Mouse started
writing the rules of Canon for Star Wars
this is what it sounds like to me
oh [__]
he [__] pulled out the d word man
all about that D yeah all right so let's
just all admit that [__] for the sake
of moving forward we don't know why
people don't turn off other people's
[__] lightsabers brilliant [__]
move I would say but oh well
plot armor
so Ahsoka watch it skip it whatever the
[__] yes
as with all things watch it skip it
whatever the [__]
um okay there's some [__] Mark watched
some [__] give it up for Mark man we
watch things we watch some [__]
uh before we dive into news I have some
news of my own uh JC got some graphics
for me
so on September 27th we're doing an
auction now I do auctions here it's
modcast all the time before our things
but we're having this auction with
bodner's Auction House online the URL
will be in the chat or whatever the [__]
or somewhere on our page
um I'm auctioning off all my comic book
artwork the stuff that I've collected
over the years yeah it's a pretty
impressive like there's stuff I
collected from my own work so there's a
lot of Green Arrow there's a lot of
Daredevil but there's stuff that I was
collecting before I started even writing
Comics a lot of Matt Wagner up there
um there's a Frank Miller Daredevil page
up there so we start the auction it
kicks off I think you can go online and
start bidding online like right now and
then on September 27th we do a live
auction it's a Wednesday and we go for
like hours online
it's because what a great question
he asked is it because my house is small
now it's true I used to live in an 8 000
square foot house good we had other
people living with God that sounds
[__] braggy it sounds very [__]
like just threw that out like a [__]
one percenter I was like you know we've
all lived in an 8 000 square foot house
I did I used to have it was Ben
Affleck's house and I've lived in it for
like 20 plus years so much so that I've
never stopped calling it Ben Affleck's
house but still I've been in it for a
long time uh once the kid moved out and
got her own house and once Jen's parents
moved out
um suddenly there were two of us walking
around this gigantic [__] house it
was like a scene from Citizen Kane with
her doing puzzles on the floor and [__]
so I was like let's get out of here man
that didn't work out well for those
people so I was like let's get the [__]
out of here they're fine yeah her
family's great her's family doing okay
so we found a place in Studio City it's
a lovely [__] house man it's great
especially for the two of us and the two
dogs the two dogs by the way have made
their way out here they're going to be
out here I'm out here in Jersey for like
a good month and [__] doing what I'm not
supposed to say but
um my dogs have come out and so they
arrived early today they weren't
supposed to arrive until Sunday and they
arrived two days [__] early and the
whole idea for them to arrive Sunday was
we rented an Airbnb with a yard and
stuff right now the dogs are up in the
apartment and the apartment I live in
the apartment that's above the movie
theater it's adorable it's like a like a
cobbler living in a giant shoe
but there's no room for two German
Shepherds upstairs and that yet that's
where they are right now
um so I know I'm Gonna Leave Here when
we're done with the show go upstairs and
find mountains of dog [__] and [__]
my sneakers will have been eaten and
stuff like that but yeah they're out
here for the Journey of a [__]
lifetime
um so anyway wait what does that have to
do with my auction nothing nope
that is the house too small the house
too small thank you so yes the house we
used to have all this wall space in the
house we lived in but in going down to 3
000 square feet who lost a lot of wall
space so at that point I was like well
this shit's gonna go into a storage unit
or I can make it available to the public
and stuff not to mention we are in the
middle of two [__] strikes we are
indeed it's been a weird business year
so not just the house is smaller but
also I'm poorer I guess is what I'm
getting at and I gotta raise a little
bit of loot so we're having this auction
with bodners man beautiful [__]
pieces of artwork you can start bidding
now and then live on November 20 not
November September 27th we'll be
auctioning and stuff lots of Greater can
I get some [__] [__] yes jump in there I
will give you a vegan cheeseburger
because I am also on strike and have no
money but I would like some cool [__]
so let me [__] vegan wimpy or like
and I will give you a vegan cheeseburger
for a piece of art today I have a truck
full of vegan jerky and I would like a
daredevil page please yeah that there of
a page is nice there's a lot of cool
pieces in there including all the covers
that Matt Wagner did for my green arrow
run and stuff so they'll fetch some
decent prices but you can go bid all the
starting bids are low it's like 10 bucks
and [__] so you can get in on the action
even if you don't think you're gonna win
you don't know could be somebody who's
like I don't [__] want that you'll
walk away with a piece for 10 bucks I
think there's a very rare piece that we
were talking about remember we met the
dudes on the strike line yes Brian K
Vaughn they brought up pieces from
Hitman where Batman has his shoes thrown
up on I think I have that page in there
yeah yeah this magic trayvonne was
looking for that piece yeah yeah and
talked about that specifically
um so there it is folks the bodners
auction happened September 27th or you
could start bidding today all the
information is up there on the website
um can't wait it's gonna be a good time
can't wait to see who gets these pieces
what they go for it's [__] fun I love
auction life
um all right what do we got news time uh
we got a little bit of news uh news has
sort of slowed to a bit of a trickle
given that in Hollywood nobody's buying
anything nobody's making anything that's
true uh nothing is in development
nobody's casting anything so all of the
things we would normally talk about are
not happening but we still found some
[__] took some doing what we found some
[__] I had to dig deep to dig really
[__] deep
uh should we talk about it we should
Mark Bernard used to cover the news man
before he did anything else every once
in a while when we're doing this show he
goes back to the news and he brought
some news for us tonight give it up for
Mark Bernard with the news
[Applause]
uh yeah finding news right now is other
than the strike what stories are there
it's uh it's a little bit hard but every
now and again there's some cool comic
book [__] okay there's a there has been
a wave of like release date shifts
uh mostly because what has happened
especially with the actors being on
strike is that they can't promote
anything yeah and which we saw with Blue
Beetle they felt like Blue Beetle was
hindered by folks not being able to go
out and do some press also hindered by
the big storm are you back were you home
for the big storm I was uh for those
don't follow California had like weather
for the first time ever they gave us I
know there was like a tropical storm and
it wasn't like a moderate 78 degrees it
was [__] there was a well it became a
tropical tropical storm starters they
were like it's a hurricane morning and
in case you've never been in Los Angeles
when the hurricane is coming it's like a
comet is about to [__] yeah like you
guys their sandbags run on food like
it's gonna be [__] crazy and it was
like it rained a bit yeah
and there were mudslides because there's
always mudslides when it rains
um and it was a little chilly because
it's always chilly when it rains but
that's kind of it right it wasn't the
snow apocalypse that everyone was no no
and I'm like I'm from the East Coast
[__] this is just like a bad
day in October yeah
I've been tempered in East Coast weather
this is [__] nothing yeah get that
weak [__] off my track
um but yeah so the storm apparently
might have stopped four people from Los
Angeles from going but they like shut
down the Alamo Drafthouse theater
they're like because of inclement
weather we just want to be safe is that
right but you're indoors we're gonna
[__] Drive-In yeah and also people
like to go to the movies when it's
raining yeah simmer down
um but so uh a movie that I was
desperately looking forward to that was
supposed to open in 2023 in a couple of
months has now shifted to 2024. uh-oh we
will have to live a little bit longer to
live long with the fighters
has been delayed to 2024. oh [__] yeah
and that's a Warner Brothers movie March
15th is when we will have to wait to see
so this is a company that's like look we
were able to advertise Barbie uh we
can't advertise this movie forget it
we'll just wait until we can throw
Timothy chalamet out there and [__]
absolutely and so it's a good sign that
means they feel the strike will be over
by then well it'd be a better sign if
they left it in November true
good point yeah that show's like no
faith whatsoever we're not getting done
with this until the end of the year yeah
true um which is like not awesome but
also like do what you're gonna do we'll
get it eventually
um I also didn't know that there was a
Godzilla versus Kong the new Empire
movie
which I was also Warner Brothers it's
also Warner Brothers and that's now
shifting back a month
um to April 12th but you know we're
still going to see [__] Wonka and the
Marvels apparently and what did you
think of that Wonka trailer
you know like
there there is never another Wonka
that's not Gene Wilder right I kind of
don't care like I like chalamet I think
it's like whatever but I never get the
feeling that he might kill a kid
and Gene Wilder absolutely [__] shiv
the [__] if you just like ate the wrong
candy
there was a sense of danger to his Willy
Wonka because it was almost it was very
sociopathic to some degree like I don't
care what happens to you whatever will
happen to him you could either die at my
hands or inherit all of this yes you get
nothing yeah it's like that dude yeah he
would happily just watch a child float
away Into The Ether yeah just so he
could figure out a new corporate CEO
um so like Sean I'm sure it'll be fun in
their songs and whatever and it's a dude
who did Paddington too I think and I
love everybody do you not love Pat I
said everybody loves Paddington too I've
never seen it
it's over 86 minutes I don't know what
to tell you it isn't though it isn't
I've never seen but I've heard everyone
I know who loves it likes just speaks
highly of it I've never met anybody it's
like [__] Paddington and Paddington too
they're always just like all Paddington
too is like The Godfather Two of
Paddington movies man
it [__] just it creates a whole new
saga for Paddington I put it on my top
10 list the year it came out you're like
Paddington too I was like [__] yes
Paddington too feel some Joy [__]
you're gonna want this and I made a
mental note like one day I'll get around
to that yep hadn't happened yet so
whatever so this is the same cat did
Patty this is the same cat
um so yeah [__] Dune part two has
been delayed thanks to the uh Alliance
of Motion Picture in Television Studios
producers [__] around and not making
a deal with the writers
boo give me dude boo indeed
now we gotta wait for another movie or
two yeah [__] them uh you're talking to
a [__] film exhibitor somebody that
owns a movie theater so as much as
you're like I don't get to watch my
movie for a few months I'm like who the
[__] is gonna come to my theater man
like ain't no Dune there ain't no what
was the other thing uh Godzilla versus
Kong which we didn't even know was
coming but there ain't none of that
ain't none of that you know what that
means then what is it it means you have
to program the OG Dune and the [__]
news [__] Dune oh yeah in your
theater we did that once remember we
showed Dune yeah [__] nine people
showed up
no they did it was [__] it was the
other one that nobody showed up for
streets of fun Streets of Fire yeah we
had like 100 people here for Dune did we
really yeah
I mean I might have to well no I got
another thing that I want to do what do
you want to do because this the thing
we're doing tomorrow is the thing that
Mark came up with while we were doing
the last episode of fat man beyond
talking about he was like we should do a
film festival Tim Curry movies called
keep calm and Curry on and we didn't do
a festival but we are doing the double
kill only because we couldn't think of a
third yes which is so weird because
everyone was just like uh Rocky Horror
Rocky Horror yes Oscar and FernGully and
Oscar
um also we could have done Muppet
Treasure Island we could have to see
so Ernie thought of that too Ernie's
like why didn't we do Muppet Treasure
Island we'll do that as a separate
Muppet event because Muppet [__] does
well for us unless I don't know if we
could show because it might be Disney
right uh I don't know who has the
distribution rights to those older
movies but to the older movies yes but
uh like a universal had Muppet movie but
Muppet Treasure Island might be flat at
Disney which means we can never get
access to it
um but I got another idea tell me uh I
you know how I am notoriously a [__]
when it comes to horror movies yes I
want to do the hunt for dead October and
program some horror movies nice which
ones from a guy who never watches them
what did you pick I want to do the thing
which was a yeah which one black and
white or John Corbin no John Carpenter
come on and who did that does anyone
know uh
Universal Universal John Carpenter
well done my friend
Universal so that will be easy to get
that'll be easy to get I want to do Zack
Snyder's Dawn of the Dead
nice who did that
Universal also Universal easy to get so
far you're batting a thousand and I want
to do Evil Dead 2.
and who has evil dead too
is that Warner Warner Brothers not
Disney not Disney Warner Brothers easy
to work with as well [__] we get all
those moves get all those movies see and
you want to do the hunt for dead October
yeah how can I win this October coming
up this October coming up who wants to
go
we'll get it going see
if I can pitch you a [__] slogan you
got good ideas it kind of Rhymes what
kind of fun can I do that's how we got
here I mean we're actually like tomorrow
night for the double feature I think
we're at 170 or something like that it's
pretty sweet though that many people
like [__] yeah I'll watch clue and then
legend for one price yeah which yeah
tickets are still available if you're
watching at home and you're like what
the [__] clue end Legend all I have to
do is get to New Jersey let me check the
airlines
did you fly out for that did you from
where
you flew out for Michigan welcome give
it up to the michiganders
what about you where'd you come in from
Oregon give it up for Oregon that's a
[__] huge trip
from Buffalo [__] hey today what
about you in the back
Los Angeles
that's where we normally do this
England what the [__] England
the one that's overseas
not the new one that we got here
[__] hey hopefully you got other [__]
to do while you're here
you came up just for this
[__] hey man why didn't anyone else
come from England
did you you're also from England
that'd be amazing if you're like it's
you bloke it's you mate
cool blimey the only two British people
into our [__] what part did you come
from
London literally from London you also
from London from where
what's it called Wakefield so from
London and Wakefield [__] a man
544 kilometers to get here
what is that in real math
what is that in the math that nobody
else in the world uses
five thousand miles
so that's like 7 000 miles
geez Louise that's a long ass trip man
well thank both yeah man coming
you're a flight attendant you work the
flight out here
and then got moving from New York
theater so how long were you
right off the plane like [__] people
like you were here your final
destination like [__] off I'm going to
fat man beyond
somebody get this man a Celsius he's got
to be exhausted truly he's only slept a
few hours at 24. that's awesome whenever
I get off planes I'm never like I wonder
where the flight attendant's going and
in this instance had I gotten off that
flight you would have been like I'm
going where you're going yeah can I bum
a ride yeah jump in my car [__] that's
awesome man a lot of people from outside
the area all right what else you got
um you were a big Veep fan huge Veep fan
just watched it again last night I'll
put on an episode and go to sleep to it
I woke up this morning 12 hours later
and it was on like 10 episodes later
it just runs in my sleep I love it so
much
um Armando iannucci he's the guy that
created it he created Veep he also
created what was the British show he did
uh think of it yeah think of it yeah
well done with one of the doctors from
Doctor Who yeah
that's right that was before he was a
doctor who died pounding Capaldi
um you say Cabela yeah what's the movie
you love the one with the [__]
hairdresser right he's talking about
Star Wars the hairdresser who [__]
[__] a robot
happened
Star Wars anyway that makes me want to
watch Star Wars again
the way you describe it I was like that
can be sold like that
um he's written a short story for uh for
Daredevil are you serious in the comics
in the comics I love when legitimate
people take interest in the [__] that I
like yeah like he's written a short an
Amazing Spider-Man short for uh for
Amazing Fantasy 1000 and now he's doing
a [__] uh Daredevil short [__] a
man that was one of my favorite
characters as well I was always drawn to
him because he had a Catholic background
I was like I did that [__] I know what
that's about
um and he also mentioned that he's
working as an executive producer on a
new American TV show for HBO about the
making of a fictitious superhero film in
Hollywood called the franchise oh [__]
um and so now I want to see that I'm
down like a clown for whatever he does
he's talented that Veep was wonderful
yeah
um finally last piece of news last piece
of news because again the [__] the
the larders are bare yeah see British
[__]
that was just for you just for you guys
classy educational [__]
um for the first time uh Disney plus is
printing uh I know see I'm fancy and
very fancy
um One Division the Mandalorian and Loki
are being released as 4K UHD and Blu-ray
later this year
um surprisingly they've never [__]
minted discs for [__] for their own
shows because the idea is they're
driving you to sign up as a subscriber
yeah and then they were like but we
could make money and money's great and
uh so they're going to sell physical
copies they're gonna sell physical
copies and so if you loved those shows
um you know no longer have to worry
about them being yanked from a service
because nobody's watching them you can
own them again like we used to do yeah
um like we used to spend billions of
dollars to buy [__] which ones are doing
one Division One Division uh Loki season
one
um and Mando season one and season two
they'll make a lot of money when does it
come out
um Loki season one is September 26th one
division is November 28th uh Mando
season one
um and season two are both on December
novel gift for Star Wars or Marvel fan
that says I care enough but not that
much you know what I'm saying like if
you bought them like Amanda season one
somebody'd be like oh I would never
think to buy this for myself but like
that's why it's a gift I know you loved
it and watched all of it but yeah
just in time for Christmas and or
indigenous people's day and or
Thanksgiving
that's right it's a perfect Thanksgiving
gift
which is what we always do yeah here
have this turkey
um why do you think they're doing it
they want money I think so I think all
of these companies are beginning to
realize that you think they want money
or they're doing it because they love us
parking lots
but like video used to be the driving
force of Hollywood [__] yeah like well I
still have a career man because even if
my [__] didn't like do theatrically well
at home video it did very well that's
why my career like that's why I got as
far as I got when I got there yeah I
mean it used to be that you could make a
movie and your first big like it's the
reason why anybody give a [__] about
Princess Bride it flopped in theaters
yeah and then Generations discovered it
on VHS on LaserDisc on DVD on Blu-ray
because it just kept on being rented and
bought and passed along and it used to
be the the driver of how Hollywood used
to work a thing didn't need to make a
billion dollars in theaters because it
could do very very well over a long
period on video and then with streaming
they just like [__] it we don't want to
make that money anymore we want to get
your 15 a month which to be fair works
for some people right Netflix does very
well getting your 15 a month uh peacock
less so
um so I think these streamers are
beginning to realize that like hey we we
had turned off a spigot that used to
give us money let's just turn it back on
again and see what happens it is kind of
found money at this point they were
never intending to do it that way and if
they just throw it out there they could
see that oh my God we could sell a bunch
of units why not yeah I mean we and then
exactly everything old is new again
we're like holy [__] if you sold the
thing people might buy it fancy that
what a great question would actors get
residuals on those shows if they were
doing physical media don't they have to
it depends on the contract they signed
because that contract May or not yeah
that's right language about physical
media
um
it would yeah it's nice look at this
town yeah step on some dicks well done
and [__] you know and also like it's
they're they're gonna start I think the
first two seat two episodes of strange
new worlds is going to air on CBS I
don't know if those actors get residuals
for that even though it's going to be
there's going to be commercials on the
television where their episode airs
because they signed a new media contract
they signed a streaming contract that
did not have provisos I don't think for
broadcast transmission the strike has
brought a lot of attention to the
subject of residuals
um which was a word that if you knew if
you were familiar with back in the day
meant somebody working on a TV show or
something like that was seeing money for
the rest of their lives and it's true to
some degree
um like there are people you know we
made Jane saw and Bob Strike Back over
20 years ago at this point and there are
still people that talk about like oh I
got my check for Jay and Bob 12 cents
but like you know it's still the trickle
down then there are people like like
Joey Adams was in Big Daddy and her
residual checks are like still [__]
substantial like couple thousand bucks
and stuff like that yeah so if you're in
a very successful movie you can live off
those residuals in a very successful TV
show you could live off those residuals
but lately like the thing to do has been
to show your residual checks for
streaming shows and how [__] minimal
they've been yeah I mean and I think the
most famous example was the actress I
think Sarah Ramirez is her name who's on
Orange Is the New Black which was one of
the biggest shows on Netflix and she was
like I've made maybe a hundred dollars
in residuals total right for my time on
that show and she would show off her
check of 12 13 14 cents
and so I mean residuals began as I mean
we're gonna get super inside Hollywood
baseball but like if you're an author
you write a book you get royalties on
the sales of those books because every
time they sell a copy of the book you
get a little get a piece of it but in
Hollywood the studios when they buy your
screenplay they take over the copyright
of that screen right and so you no
longer get royalties for the sale of
each thing but to make up for it they
invented residuals where for each sale
you got some there's a whole schedule
where the first time it's replayed you
get X and then Y and then Z and then Z
minus and Z minus and Z minus and it
trickles a couple bites at the Apple
couple bites of the Apple and so it used
to be a thing where if you wrote an
episode of Magnum PI you could be
reliably
um count on the fact that it would rerun
a bunch of times there was there were
reruns on the air remember that like hey
cheers I love that episode will I ever
see it again sure wait till summer and
will we run the entire [__] season
over the summer and then it'll go into
syndication we'll run the entire [__]
season then and that got to be a way
people could survive between jobs and
you could go years between jobs and that
would let you pay your rent that would
let you like pay your mortgage let you
put a kid in through school
with streaming most of those residuals
have kind of evaporated and kind of gone
away and nobody's re-running anything on
TV anymore unless it's [__] Seinfeld
or or you know Bob's Burgers which I
think not gonna look sideways at I
[__] love me some Bob's Burgers but I
think it's that it's so there's no
chance to watch something more than once
because there's constantly new content
coming out used to be a time where [__]
would shut down right like you'd be
between TV Seasons or you'd be between
like you know Summer movie season and
then the fall Academy Award type stuff
and then so there was time to like
Kickback and anticipate something now
it's just like hey man new Star Wars
came out this week and you're like what
the [__] seriously and next week
something else is going to happen that's
going to completely knock it out of the
news cycle so you're lucky if you
watched it from the beginning because
otherwise you got to catch up because
something brand new is [__] coming
out so there's never a chance to kick
back and be like oh my God remember
watching that thing let's watch it again
like the entire era of us growing up and
re-watching the [__] out of Caddyshack
will never happen again like how could
you re-watch a thing you like when you
can unless you're watching friends in
your sleep just turning it on and
[__] going to sleep or something like
that or Veep in your sleep as well but
generally speaking it's like there's no
time to keep up with what's new let
alone reappreciate what's old I mean
although every now and again you get
like suits yeah like that's been the big
story of the strike suits for I don't
know why
um there's lots of theories as to why
but suits went from being like a show
that was on when characters were wanted
on USA to now the most popular TV show
on Netflix right like billions of
minutes of Suits have been watched in
the last couple of months
and uh the Creator was like yeah I'm
getting about three grand for having
created [__] suits despite the fact
that it's the most popular show on
Netflix by far
because the formula just doesn't work
the way that should compensate him for
mixed bags so he's like I'm proud as
[__] but I'm not making any money I'm
not making any money and and who knows
why because yeah Netflix has a [__] ton
of new stuff but everybody wanted to
watch suits and it can't just be because
Meghan Markle was on it right
um and and maybe it's because I mean I
don't know about you guys did anybody
here were you suits fans
yeah listen to all nine of you yeah all
right Jeff you've been like just leaving
your TV on Lupine [__] suits with a
bunch of people caught on right they're
like I heard that show was good it's
been in the news cycle a lot so now
people are jumping on again and again
yeah but like every now and again
there's a show like Lucifer was that way
on Netflix before that where it was like
oh hey there's seven seasons of a show
that's not demanding of me right you
know like suits does not require
Advanced intellectual capacity like not
like Ahsoka each
you know you just jump in any episode of
Suits and they'll catch you up it's a
procedural it's like all right the case
of the week what are we doing on suits
today we're putting on our suits and
we're doing lost [__]
great and so is that what the show's
about
they call it suits it was on USA right
yeah I remember pitching at USA years
ago I forget what it was for but it was
during the stoner period and stuff and
so when I went into pitch I was like
we're at USA right and he's like yeah
and I was like that's where you guys do
suits and he's like yeah and I was like
that's the show about twins right
and the guy goes twins no and I was like
well I see on the billboard that you do
it's the same dude isn't it
and he looks at me and he goes those are
two different white guys
I was like get the [__] out of here I
said every time I see that billboard I'm
like that's the show about twins that
wear their suits
but they were not the same actor
they're two different guys that's the
greatest thing I've ever heard they're
like oh these white dudes look the same
to me
I thought it was just two of the same
dude and they play as Twins or whatever
this is a cloning show but they were
literally two different guys one of them
was why would they hire two dudes that
look so similar
because welcome to television is it part
of the plot like [__] this dude looks
like that dude just find me a handsome
white dude and then another handsome
white dude then I bet you they look a
little the same I think that I mean look
nothing taken away from the show I've
never seen it but I think that's a real
mistake in casting I think you gotta
cast two different looking people like
[__] Luke Skywalker don't look like
Princess Leia and the story and [__]
but the hair both Jay doesn't look like
Bob that's right nobody ever looked at
the poster for Jay and saw and Bob going
like twins
but suits they're both wearing suits
they're both pretty white
you're not even wearing a black suit and
a yellow suit yeah [__] it's crazy in
any event I remember the dude was like I
didn't they didn't buy my pitch
and I think the guys because the guy was
like the show about twins you know
nothing about our Network
one talks one doesn't is that what
happens on twins no I mean it's not
called twins
I'm like do you know what the most
watched show in the world is right now
twins
no just two [__] white dudes suits I
gotta remember that suits but any event
would you want to be a part of something
that's like the most watched thing which
would be more important to you just the
credit of like oh I [__] created that
thing or I'm one of the two white guys
in suits
or would you like I'd rather have the
[__] money you can only have one I
know you should have both and that's
what we're fighting for but in a world
where you can only have one which is
more important to you uh uh yeah give me
that [__] money is it really well
here's here's my favorite thing uh not
in the world whatever this this half an
hour yes is that uh there there are two
it's really narrowing it down my
favorite thing in the last 30 minutes
since we've been here is uh there there
are two uh creators of TV shows who work
in Hollywood right one of them is named
Alexi
he created uh the rookie rookie feds he
was on castle for a long time
um and there's another dude named Noah
who created uh Fargo
um no allegiantly right Alexi Hawley and
Noah Hawley they're Brothers
are you sure you think we think they're
suits they're literally they're they're
twins
one talks one doesn't one of them
creates massively populist entertainment
right and the other one wins Emmys
and they gotta go to Thanksgiving and
like like I got all this gold it's like
I got all this gold
I wonder which one of them feels like
how do they feel like what do their
parents say to them
so like that's I bet you their parents
are just like [__] man we should have
had more of these look at us they're
both little gold mines man
but like the the the chase between sort
of respect and and money I think I
choose the money would you really yeah I
would be the [__] I'd take the credit
all day long if somebody's like [__]
Tusk is the most watched movie in the
world I wouldn't even you know you can
keep all the [__] money just saying
that is [__] gold to my heart man
because you have money
[Laughter]
not So Much Anymore hence the auction
bodners my original comic book artwork
kids
um [__] hey that was fascinating all
right we done with the news we're done
with the news we did the news give it up
for Mark kids
[Applause]
he's still with us what's up man I will
I will say and uh you owning a movie
theater that Sunday is national day of
Cinema or movie theater National
National Cinema day yeah so
promotion with Regal about that today
movie ticket movie tickets are four
bucks if you can get out on Sunday if
you go to a Regal Cinema or other I
think participating Cinemas
um including here we're doing it here at
smart Castle uh you can go see a movie
for four bucks and then popcorn and soda
is four bucks also right is it
I don't think you can see Oppenheimer I
think it just left but yes National
Cinema day four bucks to see a movie
kids go out and do it I uh don't [__]
holiday now
yes Jen and I went and got tickets for
American Graffiti for four bucks each
for its 50th anniversary
and then had to hire a babysitter for a
hundred and twenty five dollars
oh you're still ahead of the game man
what's in 24 is what it cost you
yeah
did you notice that dude shirt which is
nothing but Victor Garber
no [__]
oh my God man in the stoner days that
would have freaked me the [__] out
Victor Garber
um all right kids uh now we should jump
into JC you got anything else
nope
Nancy went away I didn't want to [__]
go over him um okay now we come to the Q
a part of the show is that right
folks we're in a queue and we're gonna a
you got some cues we got some A's and
the rest of the world is gonna hear it
man
um we ready to do this [__]
get her done
I'll let you pick oh I get to pick oh
[__] look at all these hands
and do each go all translate or you come
up here and ask the question too uh I
saw I saw her hand first Gina get on up
here give it up for Gina man
[Applause]
I'm gonna give you my microphone here we
go
okay since you were talking about Ahsoka
before
um they're like a gazillion in one Star
Wars Universe shows so if you could pick
anything in the universe and that goes
for characters places
miscellaneous things uh which would you
like to see a full series be made about
in the Star Wars Universe give it up for
Gina
in the Star Wars Universe yeah I mean
[__] there's so many options
I'll give you a second to think
we didn't even have a chance to start
thinking yeah man go ahead what I would
love to see they did a series of books
called Rogue Squadron and wraith
Squadron which was just wedge Antilles
leading a bunch of hot shot Pilots
through different missions like mission
of the week in X-Wing Fighters that's
what I want to see
22 Episodes a season five seasons make
it for TV
I don't know if they're gonna give you
22 after he wants those soft on Ahsoka
bro
it's uh it's uh like [__] you 22
Episodes I mean I
want to make it because they keep
canceling Patty Jenkins movie about that
very thing so but I'd say that's what I
want to see so you just want like like
space above and beyond but in the Star
Wars universe
I want to go back to a deep cut from
[__] uh when we used to do smodcast
and it would be a Jar Jar Binks series
called Misa kills
it's all about taking you to the dark
side of [__] jar jar man he was done
getting [__] [__] on and he's just
like
stabby yes
if I can't do that
um then I would do you know what I think
would be kind of hot man is like if they
did a series
all about the animals of the Star Wars
Kingdom so like people that bring where
do you get tontons and train them to
[__] ride somebody on their back what
was the first tauntaun's reaction to
that like [__] you
like get off my back they weren't they
didn't know what would happen to their
[__] fronts later on and she was like
but that do backs like first
[__] is like let's train this do
back to ride banthas
so just want like a rodeo show Like a
Star Wars I just I just want like a
Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom
Star Wars
yes where you just go around you're like
this is a due back
this is a rankle you know it could be he
could be foreign
what about you uh I I kind of want a
young Mace Windu show nice
but only if he's like just young Sam
Jackson yeah like I don't I don't like
whatever but he's going to [__] way
out with cheese some [__] and
like like I just I basically wanted to
be his [__] Jewels but with a
lightsaber
uh no no hair though are you still gonna
be binged it off with his lightsaber but
he's got to have a goatee though because
he's also bad he's like Hawk from uh
from Spencer for Hire wow but also with
a lightsaber wow nicely done right shaft
he's a bad Jedi and it's all mace which
is all [__] mace all day it's like
what's he doing today he's gonna [__]
lightsabers and fools he's gonna shut
off your lightsaber why because he's bad
[__] shut your mouth
so that's the opening fight scene as he
turns somebody's lightsaber off right
and then two people like you can't do
that according to [__] Cannon man
[__] yeah
according to Jedi rules we don't do that
click click [__] strong
um all right man good question let's do
it I'm here oh got an answer go ahead
Ben bamboo said in chat Like a Star Wars
variety show but like what if you did it
like Twilight Zone or X-Files where it
was like the weird [__] that happens in
the Star Wars like the Unsolved
Mysteries of the Star Wars universe
I mean you're mad at them for Ahsoka
you're asking for a lie man
that Sounds Clever I'd [__] watch
that the Twilight Zone of Star Wars
shows people are like we have so much
[__] Star Wars now we're doing
Twilight Zone versions of Star Wars
and what if yeah that's a good point
that because what if for Star Wars the
thing that I that I kind of loved
um or almost loved about Kenobi
was that there's a there's a version of
Kenobi that ends with Luke Skywalker
dying
and Obi-Wan training Leia
right like so suddenly you're in a whole
different [__] Universe where I don't
know what's going to happen the problem
with with Kenobi was always there's no
outcome of this that I don't see coming
you know I know that that kid is going
to survive so whatever [__] fake
Jeopardy you give Luke will be that guy
but what if he didn't have to and so I
always thought that there was some
opportunity in the Star Wars Universe to
give you that what if what if
he didn't [__] survive that what if
[__] lay is a Jedi from birth what if
what if whatever you want that's true um
I think there's there's so much
opportunity there and a way to refresh
Star Wars for those of us who know it
too well potentially okay like uh Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood ending for
Kenobi right right that more people
would know who those characters I think
of it as the Inglorious Bastards and
yeah more than once upon a time in
Hollywood
yeah because I remember there were so
they could do a version where they're
like the [__] Luke launches at the
Death Star and he misses and it lives
and [__] yeah and like Luke just spends
the rest of his life as like the dude
who didn't destroy the Death Star yeah
like it could have been a real hero man
but you trusted the [__] Force
dummy I know he's like the dude
hey man I got close to [__] literally
ties the room together man
um that'd be that'd be that'd be down
for that that's cool idea I'd be down
for Star Wars what if uh all right
questions question round two
you come on up join us right here
DJ give it up for DJ everybody
[Applause]
tell them your name DJ
uh DJ
okay so now that we're in a world where
you know Marvel and DC have kind of like
you know the starting five is kind of
you know out of the way and you're on
the bench characters and you're doing
stuff like Echo shows and all that
what's like a a sub-tier character like
be your C tier that you guys would want
to write for whatever me whether it's
Comics movie TV show that you think
would be interesting just a pluck some
weird obscure character that people
don't know like Blue Beetle like Jaime
Reyes Blue Beetle and write for them in
some form
hmm
give it up for DJ
in the Marvel Universe
or DC in the Marvel Universe they did a
comic book series years and years ago
and we're talking 30 years ago called
fool killer which I always really loved
you remember full killer [__] that'll
make a good ass series or something like
that but you're talking deep Cuts
although not as you know about as deep
as Guardians of the Galaxy when they
announced that and they turned it into
something special
um his outfit it was an old Marvel
character and then they kind of updated
him and his outfit was kind of kooky but
he was like a vigilante
um full killer he killed [__] fools
it's right there in the title and [__]
um so yeah I would go for him for uh for
Marvel let me see on the DC side I mean
I always say this so it's nothing new
the question is my favorite DC property
which I think would make an excellent
live action uh piece man because
the question has no eyes sockets no nose
holes no mouth no ear holes it's just
this [__] flesh like the face with no
[__] features that is so unnerving
like if you turn around an Alleyway and
you saw Batman it'd be like who's got
that much money to dress up like this if
you turn around you saw a dude with no
[__] face you would piss yourself and
surrender instantly because you're like
Up Is Down black and white what the [__]
is going on
I think that would look cool rendered in
the real world and we've seen it in
horror movies sometimes they do people
with like no features like even in um
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness at
one point uh [__] black Bolt's mouth
went away right imagine taking all that
[__] away it's just horrifying so those
would be my two what's yours I think for
Marvel
um they they they glance at it in the
MCU but I've always loved uh damage
control oh yeah as an idea do a whole
last book about that a whole last show I
mean there's there's a workplace comedy
to be had and the people who have to
clean up after
you know [__] Galactus comes to Earth
and destroys most of New York but then
they've got to [__] rebuild New York
by the next day so that people don't
[__] lose their minds and it's a
workplace comedy it's a workplace comedy
it's the insurance agent's lives
construction people who [__] rebuild
easily do the office in the Marvel
Universe yeah so I've always loved that
like because it's funny and ridiculous
and also good superheroes so that makes
sense
um I think and this is based entirely on
on like six minutes from the Constantine
movie
that was with Keanu Reeves Papa midnight
uh I think it's like a fantastic
character and so evocative
um I would love to do a a real like Papa
midnight
show
um not really a movie because I don't I
don't know if there's like the bigness
of a movie that doesn't feel like
Constantine but you could do episodic
but episodic you know you get to be like
X-Files but also like magic and horror
[__] and I think there's he's super can
we get German Hunter back to play
[__] probably midnight for a show
good pull no I just saw him in Gran
Turismo so he's on my mind no
um all right [__] two fine answers
there well done kids all right we go for
third question every third question uh
do with a mustache yeah you do that no
not you
the dude behind you see that's a Mustang
dude's like I am a dude with a mustache
we'll get to you Mike come on up man
what's your name captain
give it up for v v
now that's a mustache thank you very
much uh and thank you for coming here
huge fan and very very happy to be here
uh my question is about the state of
Marvel
um and what you guys think about that
today
so I heard this on a podcast somewhere
and I thought that it was a very
interesting idea that uh Michael Jordan
was bad for basketball because he was so
good that nothing ever lived up to that
for anyone ever again
and I think that that's kind of what
happened with The Avengers end game it
was so good that we just haven't liked
anything as much after
um and just the thought of that kind of
sits with me and and I just wonder what
you guys think about that
is is Marvel bad for movies or was
endgame bad for Marvel I think his end
game was end game bad for Marvel yes uh
yes and no
it known as much as what a Triumph it
was to tie all those movies together
bring all those characters together and
what they said was one ongoing storyline
that they didn't plan for in the
beginning but kind of hoped for and that
eventually manifested it's a [__]
magic trick you know people will try to
replicate that and never be able to
replicate it and stuff it was just a
series of happy accidents that led to
like a finely paved Road and a landing
strip for [__] entire series to come
in for a graceful graceful Landing the
problem is is there was a graceful
landing and it told this gigantic
sprawling story and tied up a lot of
loose ends now
doesn't mean that you know those
characters can't warrant more
storytelling which as we've seen they
were just like let's keep going and of
course they assumed rightfully that's
what we wanted just more and more and
more
but there has been this kind of like
since end game because endgame was so
[__] epic and something that even if
you love those movies you never thought
you'd see in this lifetime
so I think they have had a hard time
topping themselves and it feels like I
mean you know the the easy answer would
be like well they should have stopped at
end game but like that was never gonna
[__] happen because they could still
print money off these things
but I feel like a lot of people checked
out with endgame where they were just
like well that's it for me I saw my
Marvels and I'm good and once they
started being like well hold on there's
[__] five new TV shows that's when
people were like that's too much [__]
time you can get me for like a movie or
two a year but what the [__] like 10
episodes in a row [__] this noise so you
had a lot of attrition a lot of people
jumping off and whatnot I don't know
that it means the quality is necessarily
gone downhill although I will say this
when they started making this [__] they
didn't know if they were going to be
making this [__] right they're making
Iron Man like we hope this [__] works
so they dreamed about the future they
didn't write for the future they wrote
for that one [__] movie and they put
all their talent and effort into one
story now they do that for 10 20 stories
happening at the same time and that just
becomes a question of quality control if
you're looking if your entire company is
looking at one story
every detail is going to be poured over
all the love and attention is being
poured all over that project if you're
spreading all those people out over
multiple projects
and you're all trying to meet deadlines
so that a story connects and [__] and as
we heard recently like the folks that
made the doctor strange Multiverse of
Madness movie hadn't even read Wanda
Vision you know like Wanda Vision
achieved something in and of itself and
then when Elizabeth Olsen got to set for
Multiverse she was like did you guys
see what we did on blond division
they're like there's a wand division you
know so they're all kind of creating in
the dark you know not necessarily in
collaboration anymore because there's so
many moving pieces and I think that
coupled with just like you know Mark was
talking about earlier tonight how many
times you're going to see the origin of
something where you know he describes
Blue Beetle which he enjoyed but like
describes it as like something a lot of
people have seen before
all that kind of kicks in to make it
easier for people to step away from
Marvel when they did even people that
were like never into comic book movies
who joined up for the ride and stuff but
it feels like that would have been a
jump off moment for a lot of people
um and then it just so happens that
during that next phase
they took some missteps where a bunch of
the people that were like I'm here for
ride or die for Marvel like well maybe
not that
um yeah it's it's I don't know if you
could have played it any other way other
than to like just make movies that
people cared about more or something
like that or make movies with every
character that was in
end game right because they started
telling stories without
traditional Marvel characters that
they've introduced you to over the
course of 10 15 years bless you
so um man I I don't [__] know I'm a
huge Marvel fan
but I have felt since end game it's like
well [__] man you gotta really go far to
impress they've come up with some TV
series that have been like impressive in
their own regards I thought Wanda Vision
was amazing and a big like step forward
in storytelling for them and could you
know stand shoulder to shoulder with
like Infinity war and end game it's like
you know a lot of people point to
Infinity war and end game is the last
time Marvel was quote unquote good I you
know I would say like well the big
Bellwether of that was one division it
was it captured the entire nation's
imagination at that time when they were
going Episode by episode everyone was
dialed in and kind of invested
it's tough to keep that
kind of enthusiasm going man like
especially if you're going to inundate
people constantly here's a bunch of
movies to come see to Multiplex here's a
bunch of TV shows you could watch as
well you know there's a lot to keep up
with and
it's not like Marvel had their time
they're still going to have their time
but it feels like after end game people
were like I'm satisfied like a good
section of the audience felt like they
were satisfied me I'm there every week
for it whatever they want to do I'm here
for it some stuff I know I was gonna I'm
gonna love some stuff like whatever
won't hit me as much some stuff will be
the eternals
um
but like at the end of the day I'm here
for it but I've seen a change as well
what about you
um I mean I I sort of
the the Michael Jordan analogy like I'm
not sure how solid that is given that
before Michael Jordan you had magic in
Larry Bird right
and they were playing Magic was playing
while Michael Jordan was playing after
Michael Jordan you get Kobe Bryant after
Kobe Bryant you get LeBron James like
there seems to be a kind of generational
wave that requires a bit of time between
those waves before the Apex gets to hit
and I think what happened after end game
is that there was no Lull in the wave
right like what we needed I think was
space and time away we needed a little
bit of like you got to rotate the crops
we got to let this field life follow we
got to let an audience miss us a little
bit instead they had Spider-Man
there was where they were like it ain't
just Spider-Man it's [__] Green
Goblin from a whole different [__]
movie yeah and people like holy [__]
take more of that Avengers money you
know and and I just think that that yeah
like
every story needs to have an ending
even a long-running story that you love
you know and TV has taught us that right
like other than soap operas at some
point you're coming to the end of your
story
be it three seasons be it 12 Seasons be
it one season of greatness there has to
be an ending that's how we process story
and so the idea that the Marvel Universe
story could never end made it feel kind
of like well all right hey you're
cheapening that end game a little bit by
it not being an end game just to sort of
pause in the action like a seventh
inning stretch and then coming back to
stuff that never quite hit that hard and
I like some of those movies like I like
Chong Chi quite a bit I like you know no
way home quite a bit there are some of
those movies that are good and there's
some that aren't and there's still a
half-formed Celestial somewhere in the
Atlantic Ocean that we just don't talk
about his head sticking out yeah
nobody's ever been like shouldn't we
clean that up yeah it's like flight
plans have to divert around a [__]
half-born God that's in the middle of
okay if you'll look out your window to
the right
uh you'll see a half dead or dead alien
god who's been in the ocean for quite
some time we don't talk about it anymore
but there it is kids you know like I
just he is
eternal
so I think that that's that seems to
have been some of the audience's
response
to the to the ongoing MCU initiative and
we were pummeled during the pandemic in
just post pandemic with a bunch of TV
shows some which were good some of which
not so good some of which were secret
invasion
um
somebody goes mid mid
that like
it just kept begging the question why
like why are we doing this what is the
what is the ongoing initiative that
we're building towards is it just to
have stuff to have stuff is it and and
does that service the thing that we love
anyway just more is not always better
unless it's pizza and or yeah blow jobs
um
and so like to his point it's maybe we
should have taken a break maybe we
should have given it some time for an
audience to miss it a bit more like it's
it's how I feel a little bit about Star
Wars which is Star Wars was a Nostalgia
driven Enterprise yeah and you cannot be
nostalgic for a thing you get all the
time yeah so like give me some space you
know take some time make me miss you a
little bit and then figure out for real
what you're doing next and do it well
um as opposed to just shotgunning [__]
at me like I'm a like I'm a in the
audience of a basketball game and
there's a dude just firing a T-shirt
cannon into my face and only my face
here's another shirt here's another
shirt
um so yeah like I just I I wish I wish
that I had a chance to miss it and then
I might be able to forgive the stuff
that's not that great because then I'm
just glad I got it it's supposed to be
like I could slow down buddy I don't
need any more t-shirts to the face
[__] hey man there's an answer to
that question give it up great question
we did it we did it uh
you young lady
right so like what
did you ever want
to like
you
is there is
like a superhero version a superior
version of my character
um like yeah well blunt man and chronic
was certainly that that's about as close
as I could get and feel comfortable
oddly enough because I'm like well all
this [__] is real
you know like [__] if Randall becomes
a superhero I'm like well [__] why
would that's not real
but James on Bobby could always do like
the Snoopy thing like whenever Snoopy
was flying around on a stop with camel
you know I always understood it was be
like that's what he's imagining like
that's not really happening there was no
real Red Baron and [__] like that so
that's to me was blunt man and chronic
was Jay and Son always in J and Silent
Bob's head I think that's as close as I
would get but I would do deep Dives on
like origin stories like there's a
there's in quick stops there's a
Veronica store I wanted to do about
like this is almost like Freaky Friday
where her and her daughter switched
places and she finds out like what her
mother was like and it happens on the
day of Clerks and [__] with like 37
dicks and all that [__]
so I would I might do it in that the
next they just announced it the next
Quick Stop series
um begins in November I think it is and
it's uh Cash Cow the secret origin of
mubi and it's so [__] up
it really is like one of the most [__]
up things I ever wrote and stuff it's
very like grown up and [__] very murder
mystery where you're like for movie and
you're like yeah yeah oh my God it's
[__] cool
uh what about you uh I I is there a
world in which and I'll run it by you
because this is your Universe yeah so
I'd have to get uh permission from the
license or my thank you um I I love
because I think there was a soap opera
that did something like this at some
point where like it was just [__]
average mundane [__] for like 20 years
and then they decided oh yeah by the way
there are vampires importance yes yeah
you know General Hospital like up their
Auntie quite a bit where suddenly the
storylines were like that's more comic
book than yeah is there a Wither
dominator in [__] Port Charles yeah
there is
um and so the idea that like it's a
little Shawn of the dead but it's like
hey so like are there vampires in this
world and just they don't notice because
they don't give a [__] right and then
slowly people start getting bitten and
they're like how come nobody's coming
out during the day anymore I don't
[__] know snooch
so we know who said that
we know how that goes and then like
Silent Bob gets bit and then suddenly
gets like really talkative and seductive
because he's been bitten by like [__]
the Frank langella version of Dracula
it's so weird like I'm I'm reacting
poorly to this because I'm like that
would never happen
but I know we're make-believing and [__]
so I should ease up and be okay with it
but I'm like no [__] no if they get
bit then one of them has to die
no it's not zombies it's vampires
nobody's gonna die right but then if you
don't kill him he turns other people
into vampires and [__]
then the whole yeah like if it was Dante
like Dante had to die that's why I
killed him in clerks three so he didn't
become a [__] vampire
spoilers I mean all I'm saying is that
like the Quick Stop could eventually
become like a blood bank
that Vampires will show up to that's
only open like 7-Eleven vampire clerks
vampire clerks Transylvania Clerks
we hit it you see
clerkula
screams clerculus scream
that's for super Veronica
she's pushing super Veronica [__] hey
yeah did you copyright super Veronica
I mean I'm just in this [__] vampire
clerks world right now I know you're
writing over there once again you're
sharing a good idea shut the [__] up hey
man I can't do anything with this stuff
unless you say so where else do we want
again who else got questions go ahead
all right I'm gonna go over the other
mustache guy because I feel bad yeah
nice
the time to [__] vindicate him what's
your name
Joe Give It Up to Joe Joe's Next
[Applause]
uh in the Mandalorian season one episode
five the Mandalorian ends up in
tattooing and he goes to Cantina in Star
Wars Obi-Wan and Luke going to The
Cantina are told that to draw the droids
aren't allowed there but when the
mandalorians there the droids are
working there so if you could go and see
another location years later at how it
changed what would it be
give it up for him great question
[Applause]
so what would I like to go and it's in
the Star Wars universe any place
a place we visit one point and then the
story catches up with it years hence
that's true I mean I kind of lived it a
little bit with clerks three
but if I was to go back to a place that
they never went to back to in the Star
Wars Universe like I always thought Hoth
was so amazing and how come like
nobody's ever gone back to hop
um I felt like in that one movie that
Ryan Johnson directed like remember they
were on the gambling Planet yeah and
they had sadly I remember the game yeah
they had those weird creatures that were
running around I was like why couldn't
those have been tauntons I know I'm
pushing for tauntons really hard pushing
hard
but um Hoth was you know you can go back
and be like they had a [__] huge
battle here man they had giant snow
Walkers and [__] like that
um sooner or later I bet you they go
back to ha
but what would I do if it wasn't that
like something but I would just like to
go back to I don't know I remember when
I saw the trailer for Jaws too I was so
excited that it began with the Orca sank
in the bottom of the ocean I was like
holy [__] they know about the Orca too
so I I don't know you could really
please me with anything maybe I mean
they just did it this summer in Flash
they took us back to Michael Keaton's
bat cave and I was like ah it's exactly
like I left it
and the kitchen as well yeah I'm easy to
please though what about you
um
I kind of want to see what uh what cloud
city looks like
you know years later years later like
after Lando leaves to become a [__]
space general just low bot in charge
yeah like it [__] runs right you know
like we got this [__] on them on the
money like everybody's showing up labor
is taken care of there's no issues with
like a [__] weird ass swindler making
Randall laws about [__] like no
swindling but me
um the Empire's not welcome here anymore
like I just I feel like it'd be like a
gentrified version of cloud city or
another opportunity for like a workplace
comedy
meet lobot he's in charge but he's
frustrated did I ever tell you
um I had I gotten approached and it
never really worked out
um but I think it was like Del Rey or
Random House whoever does there's a
there's a series of books that it's
called from a certain point of view
right and they're Star Wars anthologies
and it's like what you know just pick a
scene and kind of illuminate a different
thing a moment in that particular movie
that nobody's seen but might feel like
it could be in Canada but you just never
got a chance to take a look at it
um and I pitched a story they approached
me like hey do you want to write one of
these I'm like yeah and I pitched them a
story about
um the guy who trains tauntons on Hoth
right and like this is my dream [__]
story what's your dream story and it's
about like the guy who like you know he
finds his litter of tauntons and there's
one and it's like you know a little bit
you know weak as a horns aren't created
quite right but he [__] the Rudolph
of tomtoms and he's like hey man just I
love this [__] Taunton and I pretty
much I've stitched his leg I bound the
broken Limb and whatever and raised him
the the like the bottle in the mouth and
all that stuff and he's like all right
hey you're ready you're my favorite top
10 I love you so much and then in comes
[__] Han Solo who's like I gotta go
find Luke and this guy's like
all right Rudolph
I'm I'm like this is the one like you're
the strongest you're the best of them
you can [__] go and so when he tells
Han you'll freeze before you go to the
you get to the first marker right he's
like this is my favorite [__] taunt
on you son of a [__] and I'm giving it
to you because Luke Skywalker is that
important right he's like you'll get
back alive on this Tonton or or he knows
he's going to die he's like oh he knows
the tauntone is going to die like
Luke is so important he's willing to
sacrifice his favorite Taunton to let
Han Solo go out and find him he all
right so he's not doing it going like
well this is this tauntaun's [__]
dead meat yeah he is it's Old Yeller
it's like you are my favorite [__]
Taunton you're going to die out there
but you'll give Han Solo the best chance
of finding Luke Skywalker by being like
a human [__] heating compartment or
just by like you'll take him the
furthest you'll take him the fastest
maybe he's got like a five percent
better chance of finding that dumb Farm
Boy than any other Taunton I have here
I'm giving you the [__] Bambi of
tauntauns this is like the Marley and Me
of the Star Wars Universe it's the
[__] tragedy of the dude who's like
I've raised you since you were a pup now
you have to go off and die why is it
about the dude [__] him man like
tanzan's like I'm the one that gets
split open you [__] because the Taunton
doesn't talk Kevin oh good point
good point
totally so everything's projected yeah
that's true [__] man I want to see that
now you've described something in Star
Wars that I would really like to watch
yeah they were like no
and I don't know why it's amazing if
you're watching that and you're like
don't piece together like oh it's gonna
be that TomTom yeah the most famous
TomTom ever the one that [__] you of
him in like downtown City all the
tauntaunts talk about him like he's the
one that got cut the [__] open man the
first marker after he died
oh man that Tauntaun got multiple action
figures already how could you not true
write more story about something that
already had an action figure
that's true man you could buy when I was
a kid they had the Star Wars Tauntaun
with the split open belly you know
[__] Lucan exactly you didn't see his
guts or anything but you could stick
them inside the Tonton and [__]
yeah
that's amazing
all right more questions we'll do one
more and then we'll get out of here and
you sir yes with the hat come on up
what's your name
jet
chatter chat Chad give it up for Chad
everybody
so I want to say thank you Mark for
coming to the east coast
um and Kev this everything you do is
amazing the one thing I I had a question
I really wanted to ask
um but I would be remissed um this is
the first time my son has come to a
Kevin Kevin Smith show
I've come many times I gave you a
drawing I don't know if you remember but
um
can he come up and ask his question
yeah totally
like you I love my kid
um but yeah
all right father son he he
we've watched a lot of movies uh I've
showed him over the years of your movies
um and Mark this is the first time uh he
has actually met you so hi I don't
remember it if this wasn't I'm Parker
can't lose Parker uh
uh I was just gonna ask which of the
characters you've made both of you uh
what your favorite is
foreign
character out of the characters you have
made I'm sure someone has asked this
before but
I
don't think anyone has asked before give
it up for him ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
um or you could sit down let's sit the
[__] down it'd be weird for you to sit
there the whole time us talking to you
just nodding after Silent Bob it
um who has been my favorite character
that I ever created
I mean I should be like Silent Bob but
like he that was not my favorite
character that was kind of an answer to
Jay and some would say Jay but I didn't
create J J is J
so I just stole his character and put it
in a movie
Harley
that's adorable she is made of my [__]
isn't she
um partly
um
but I took it to me in like a character
I created and I would say who I love the
most
I don't know maybe Brody to some degree
because Brody is seems immortal like you
know he's he
is kind of a watcher and he also like
did a thing before the whole world did a
thing he was the internet before the
internet existed and then we all found a
bunch of brodies and we all turned out
to be brodies ourselves
um I do I like that character and I owe
that to Walt Flanagan because Walt
Flanagan was the model
for Brody and I always thought he was
just so [__] interesting I was like
here's this grown ass man that loves
comic books so deeply he'd fight for
them
like that that just really [__] drove
the the character for me and um you know
we've used him of course in Mall Rats
and then he popped up later on and Jay
and Silent Bob reboot and I've created a
lot of [__] characters but that one
what onomatopoeia that's a cool
character as well Green Arrow and that
was me adding something to a medium
that I used the medium's word I always
thought that word onomatopoeia was very
cool it means something like when you
see the word crash or smash or [__]
pal that's onomatopoeia and so creating
a character that only spoke in
onomatopoetics was kind of fun for for
comic books I feel like
that was a nice add to the medium I do
like that character but not as much as
Brody I think I think Brody's the thing
I I'm I like the most of everything like
of all my characters who would I want to
hang out with
Brody like you remind me of like a very
happy time in my life and like when I
was deeply involved in comics and [__]
when the only thing that mattered was
like you know [__] Mr Toad's Wild
Ride and [__]
that's mine what about yours
um favorite character I've created
um it's tempting to say Adora from a
door in the distance yeah
um you know who I who will you be
signing that at your signing tomorrow I
will be signing whatever people put in
front of me
um I no I for real I'll sign anything
Dick's included Dick's included uh
that's tomorrow folks if you're in the
Jersey area at Jay and Silent Bob's
secret stash we're having a signing for
Mr Mark Bernard and he's got his book
messenger just came out the legend of
Muhammad Ali indeed and he'll be signing
a a uh Adora you'll ask me son what's
your [__] Star Wars book it was a
story in Darth Vader black white and red
an anthology that Marvel did
um it's from noon till three noon to
three tomorrow news to three at the
secret stash Roll On by get something
signed by Mark and then at night we're
hosting keep calm and Curry on the Tim
Curry double feature man yes come watch
clue and Legend with us
um but I think it's it's uh Destiny Ajay
the main character of a book called
genius that I did okay
um and Destiny the the pitch of the book
is if every generation gets his military
genius and Alexander the Great uh Norman
Schwarzkopf uh Hannibal whatever what if
our Generations are military genius was
a 17 year old black girl from South
Central LA who's had enough [__] and
decides to unite the warring gangs of LA
and take on their their biggest enemy
which is the LAPD
um
and so the thing that I love about that
character is that she is
she's the loneliest character I've ever
written because she
it's a bit of the do you remember
Broadcast News yeah [__] yeah I remember
broadcasting there's a there's a there's
a question that I think a character asks
the Holly Hunter
um character it's like don't you hate
being oh don't you love being the
smartest person that's one of my
favorite scenes Cinema where he goes it
must be it must be great it must be
great to be so right all the time to be
the smartest person she's like God no I
hate it yeah she's like no it's terrible
the isolation of being brilliant the
isolation of being a little broken the
isolation of thinking nine steps ahead
but not being able to really form
friendships because there's something
deficient in her brain
um I just love that idea of somebody who
was very very good at one thing and
awful at everything else and so I just
there's something about her that I that
I keep wanting to keep writing whereas I
think a Dora's story is done like I
think and if you've ever read the book
you know the Arc of that book and
and so like I'm never like sure I can
write more stories in that world I can
even maybe make up some stories about
her but Destiny is the one that I kind
of keep coming back to and kind of keep
gravitating towards because she's broken
and I think broken characters are just
very very interesting to write and a ton
of fun and I think people
see themselves in the flawed more than
they see themselves in the perfect and
we're all a little bit broken and so
that's why I kind of love her the most
okay good answer give it up for them
kids
you got one man that shirt alone [__]
earns you come up on stage what's your
name
give it up for Tony kids
[Applause]
um it's not really a question for you to
answer it's more of a favor forgive me
I'm nervous
um
came from Oklahoma just for this oh [__]
uh and we're the wind whipping across
the plains when you left very much so
throwing me across uh but no uh
you guys to give it up for my wife
Carmen for enduring this vacation this
nerd vacation she's darling
but that's it and and thank you I listen
to you guys religious
religious so
thank you
you give it up for them give it up for
Carmen good job Tony
sometimes man there has to be the other
person in a relationship who's like I
don't know anything about this [__] but
if it makes you happy I'll be there
that's [__] wonderful right there
you need red state in what way
a medium it's come it's uh I mean not
good but I think it's coming back we've
been talking to Lionsgate about them
picking it up and re-releasing it with
the new cover and [__] so red state may
be in your future very soon
um that's so weird that like to you I'm
red State like I meet people where to me
to them I'm Degrassi
and they have no idea about the rest of
my career they're like you're the guy
from Degrassi and I'm like well I'm one
of the guys from Degrassi I I think
Drake is the guy from Degrassi now
but they're like you that's how I know
you you were undergrassi and then there
are people that just know me from
certain aspects of the work and Redstone
I'll take that I like anybody who knows
Red State uh but thank you for making
the trip from Oklahoma was it worth it
it's nice here right yeah yeah if you've
never been to Jersey kids come on
[__] visit it's a Garden State yes
[__] literally we put it on the
license plate and [__]
um and while you're here always come
visit us at smodcast Castle Cinemas
where the movies come to play that's
where we've been hanging out tonight or
you can go see Jay and some Bob secret
stash and [__] Red Bank or you can go
to the actual quick stop from those
[__] movies and stuff
do all [__] three in a day man uh
that's what you get here at the Jersey
Shore we're at a show we're out of show
we're at a [__] show kids have you
had a good time
uh don't forget come out and see us
forever we got tickets on sale for a
bunch of stuff I think November no
September 30th Babylon is coming back so
you can get tickets for that online
right now at uh smodcastcinemas.com uh
we got a bunch of movies coming up they
come see uh Tusk is coming next weekend
but it's sold out uh Jersey girl or Joey
Adams is sold out as well but we'll be
adding some other stuff uh but I'll be
around all month so we'll be doing
things and [__] uh give it up for the
guy without whom we don't get fed out
into the world man Banff man himself JC
and give it up for The Man Without whom
there is no fat man beyond the [__]
real brains of this operation marvelous
Mark Bernard and kids
and that
I guess it's fat man beyond for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard
tune in next week same fat Time same fat
Channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss everybody good
night
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask of anything every
Saga has a 10-year anniversary ladies
and gentlemen and this is what happens
with Jay and Silent Bob get old off
Kevin Smith
[Music]